is that you're not engaged in defensive doxing. You're throwing
[__] at the wall and seeing what sticks.
>> Oh, I've only doxed people that are unhinged and obsessed
about me. I'm pretty sure every person I've done has been one
of those people. >> Have you done it or have you gotten
gay ops people in DG or gay ops people in different discords
to do it? >> You lie and and defame people and you lie
and harass people. Like, you can't stop lying. Let's not forget
he fully confessed to non-consensually sending Pixie's tapes
to this 17-year-old. He totally confessed to Straight Raid that
he did it non-consensually.
And he just lies and says, "No, no, no. That's not what I meant.
I just meant like I was, you know, I was sad it leaked. That's
all I meant, guys." He just lies.
Oh, combination of both. But if somebody passes out to me, I'll
post it. I don't give a
men. I'm looking for Dubbie. Careful. Um,
how are you, Stevie? This is uh, apparently they're doing something
from the Anything else studio. Let's take a look. I'm going to,
by the way, I'm going to take full I'm going to take full credit
for this. Okay, I'm going to take full credit. Oh, whoops. I'm
take full credit for this with my Hi, I'm Connor and I approve
this message. All right, we get full credit for this. Whatever's
happening here. Okay. Whatever happens,
>> just no matter how this goes, I just don't think it
will actually turn to any like conflict. Okay. I just don't think
it can. Um any conflict would be like kind of performative and
not really matter. But maybe maybe I'm wrong. I'm I if I would
love to be wrong, okay, cuz I I used to think Connor was like
a pretty good person deep down and I just I've kind of been losing
little pieces of that along the way. >> I'm chilling. >> All
right. Well, the past two weeks have been a little crazy, wouldn't
you say? >> They sure, >> dude. What? This is real,
not AI. No, this is very real. This is very real. >> Have
been Connor. >> Excellent. So, one of the things that was
brought to my attention recently by some drama folks uh was that
I think around two years ago, I took issue with the streamer
Chudlo Logic. And the reason why I took issue with him was because
Queean >> Oh, hold on. speaking with and in my opinion
normalizing
another streamer named food shops who is an unrepentant lollycon.
>> It's been brought to my attention that you have been
raiding food shops
>> And by locon we mean lollycon enjoyer. >> Yes.
They enjoy that content. >> Okay. It's kind of
uh con means enjoyer. Loi is the word and con means enjoyer.
Lolly con. >> It is super. >> This guy doesn't even
watch anime. >> You're weird. So, I guess my question is
>> Oh, no. Probably because it reminds them of little anime
children or something. >> My question is why are you rating
them? >> Because they're my strongest soldier.
In what war?
>> In the war against evil. >> And what And what
is this definitional
>> The leftist and the tankies.
>> She's fighting the leftist and the tankies right now.
>> We're fighting Queen Majestical. Yes. >> I thought
Okay. But I thought we've
Oh, we occupy so much space in this guy's mind. Dude, the best
part is I just keep restating my opinion on that whole chorus
thing and it's like nothing to do. I like literally don't have
any super far lefty opinions on it at all. It's the same opinion
I had on PV. You're a tanky now. I guess so. I just love We're
fighting the tankies and the communists by resisting Quean and
Jto. Okay. Cream and justical were like drama frog a log commentary
people not necessarily like super politically >> Yeah,
but they're hanging on my nuts until my court case is done. >> Okay.
But so by what dragging down the the world's number one liberal
streamer, they're actually serving the interests of leftists.
>> I guess they kind of are. That's like a byproduct. They
just don't like me. >> Okay. So food shops is the number
one liberal warrior right now.
>> Okay. Well, I I I feel >> Martin Luther King cheated
on his wife with a 17-y old white girl. Okay. So, >> and
Destiny, of course, is just like Martin Luther King. Okay. He's
basically Martin Luther King. All right. Listen, would you have
stopped if M Destiny be like, would you have stopped Martin Luther
King and the entire civil rights movement just because you found
out that Martin Luther King was keeping child on his uh hard
drives? Really? Really? You would have stopped all of civil rights
just because of a little child, Connor?
Really, Connor? >> Oh, I don't know if that's true or not.
>> I don't I don't know if that's true or not. I'm sorry.
So besides maligning the the memory of the dead Martin Luther
King, which is >> the Okay, so so my beef is that
this was my beef with Queen effectively a logging, watching her
content all the time, her getting normalized in the space, and
then it seemed like Tread Logic didn't have an instantaneous
revulsion to uh the un the lack of apology or excuse me, the
apology for Lcon.
My beef with Lollcon is that it's >> I've I've always said
this, King of Sorro, that like listen, they're going to they're
going to release the dogs on us, okay? They're going to threaten
us. They're going to try to beat us down, but we will remain
civil, okay? We will win through civility. We will do it. >> As
far as I know, it's drawn
images of
underage people.
Yeah. And so >> we usually call those children. Yeah. >> Children.
Um, and so yeah, I find that repulsive and I don't think that
should be normalized. And I think the reason why it shouldn't
be normalized is because you're reinforcing a connection within
your own brain that is effectively like some people use this
defense of like, oh, it's just a drawing. It's just a drawing.
But for me, it's like it's not about the drawing. It's about
what it's doing to you, the consumer. Now, here's the here's
the real question.
Will Destiny employ the exact argumentation food shops did to
defend Loi against Connor? Because that would be
that would be cinema. Okay, that that argument if you don't remember
was Oh, are you saying that like if you play GTA then you're
going to go do a mass? That was the argument food shops did.
Will is it possible that Destiny would just actually do it bar
for bar? I don't know. Okay. >> I hope not.
>> There's two conversations.
>> One is debate about lollycon and two is a debate about
whether or not I should rate into food shops. >> Can we
>> Which one do you want to start with? >> Can we
start with lollycon, please? >> What's your favorite? I'm
just kidding. I'm kind of indifferent towards it. Basically,
I think that for most things, you have to start kind of neutral
and then you figure out if something is good or bad from there.
Like if somebody says like drinking soda, like I don't have an
opinion or consuming, you know, Marvel movies and then you go
from there. Um, when it comes to lollycon stuff, I guess the
biggest concern is are you normalizing like underage attraction
such that people are going to start acting on it or performing
it more in the world or something like that. My understanding
is that doesn't happen. Like if it did, if that was like ever
demonstrated, I'd probably feel significantly different about
it. I don't even know how you would demonstrate that. Um, but
that would be my thing. I would just put it in the kink area
like all the other kind of bad things that people roleplay like
u like consent not consent. >> How are you Stevie? >> Hold
on.
>> So, so lollycon is like CNC. Okay, hold >> Underage
attraction such that people are going to start acting on it or
performing it more in the world or something like that. >> My
understanding is that doesn't happen. Like if it did if that
was like ever demonstrated, I'd probably feel significantly different
about it. I don't even know how you would demonstrate that. Um,
but that would be my thing. I would just put it in the kink area
like all the other kind of bad things that people role play like
u like this is uh this is bordering on the ethical argument right
that child wouldn't be bad if it like if it if it satiated some
desire right this is the argument Destiny's made for like a long
time if it satiated some desire reduced that it it's like yeah
pedal roleplay okay all right
we'll see cuz I'm sure these arguments have been made to Connor
I wonder how Connor feels I wonder how Connor feels about these
>> Uh, no, but the lore for the Imperium is that they're
a xenocidal faction and they will wipe out men, women, and children
of rival species. >> Jesus Christ. >> Yeah, dude.
>> Okay. Um, okay. So, summarizing,
um, I don't care about the thing in and of itself. I think if
the thing manifests as as more things or if other stuff comes
from it, I think that would be concerning and I'd probably heavily
at least socially discourage it, if not more. Yeah. But that's
basically where I'm at. Yeah. >> Okay. than summarizing
my perspective. I'm worried that you uh and by the way like Queen
acts like oh oh Conor Connor's hanging out with Stephen. He's
still talking to Stephen. Um you know but but he holds this contradictory
view in reference to this uh topic. Quean spa espouses the same
view. I've heard him say it like plenty of times. It's just drawings
ninja and he'll use the end >> Jesus the
>> Yeah. And you went and weren't you accusing him of normalizing
food shops and you like had a whole problem with it
>> Yeah. It's awesome. But anyways, the
>> the point is that
um the point is that like number one, on an individual level,
I don't think you should entertain that. Number two, I don't
think you should entertain it with uh with your friends. Number
three, if you bump into friends who are entertaining that part
of their brain, you should push them away for it. Number four,
I think that if it hits a certain level of disgusting, it should
be uh pro prohibited eventually. And and I think that for me
um I could articulate lines of prohibition that I would follow
through with if I was allowed to. >> Okay, it's fair. >> Okay,
so that's that conversation and I feel like we dealt with that
head on even if it's uncomfortable. So putting that to the side.
>> Oh, thank God. >> In my opinion, you're too permissive,
but I have a different opinion on it. The next thing is using
food shop. >> By the way, we gained nothing from that conversation.
They both stated the same opinion. They've stated like at least
a half dozen times before, right? They both have the exact same
positions. There's no way you couldn't have just figured this
out by listening to either of them talk for like 15 minutes on
the their thoughts on the topic. There's nothing achieved by
that conversation, okay, at all. Except one thing. We get to
watch Destiny just totally humiliate Connor, not take him seriously
for like how long was that? Was uh about 30 minutes of just Connor
humiliation. We had to watch. So, in terms of content, the Connor
humiliation is kind of worth it to me on its own. you know, >> as
a weapon to fight Jtock in Queenman. So, I think that this is
>> um
a silly use of your time, energy, and talent that the conflict
doesn't necessarily call for. Um,
and that that yeah, I would never use like a flawed tool to attack
my enemies. So I guess my issue is um over the past year and
a half there's been obviously I mean you've seen it because you're
you're a part of it um or you get impacted by it is there's like
a highly coordinated network of degenerate creepy losers/
>> highly coordinated losers >> insurance company
owners um like doobie >> the only person who collects child
is this fellow this is the only one this is the only one who
holds on to child
>> all these other people who are >> I didn't say
That doobie. He said that. >> Um he said that >> who
are like con >> subtle docs. Yeah, he's been menacing Doobie
with apparently apparently Dubbie does insurance somehow
>> No, that's like the quintuple down. He's done it like
multiple times. He did it on food shops multiple times. Krueger,
he's done it multiple times since. So everybody who was a little
concerned about it just he's just making it obvious. Yeah, I
would do that. Yeah, I am threatening that >> like working.
I used to call it with in reference to a woman whose name will
never be >> Oh, sure, sure, sure. Yes. A year and a half.
Yeah, Destiny can't tell time when he's being hyperbolic, right?
So, the Pixie stuff started as of 7 months ago. Okay, basically
7 months ago, and now it's a year and a half. He's more than
doubling the time
working. I used to call it with in reference to a woman whose
name will never be bismerched here again. Kelly Jean. Um, I used
to use this phrase reputation workshopping where they would go
into Discords and they would constantly
um just like do that like work on people's reputations and make
every make sure everybody like feels the same way about things
>> to damage or to reinforce >> both. It can be to
reward. So he can show evidence of this. Yes.
other than vibes, but because I think his evidence of this is
people don't like me and that's because of these because of a
coordinated cabal to like make sure people don't like me. But
it's like, dude, people just don't like you. People don't like
people who kids repeatedly. People don't like people who hold
on to child after being informed that the the object of the is
a minor. People don't like that. People just generally don't
like this behavior. People don't like uh consent violation. You
are a master of sex consent violation. People don't like this
and they're capable of expressing that dislike and not liking
you totally on their own without me or queen to guide their way.
What they see as loyal or good behavior or it can be to damage
or attack what they see as people outgroup people basically.
>> Why should we care about their opinions at all? >> So
in the past you wouldn't care about their opinions because you
just don't give them >> decent drama content. But I'm saying
like, yeah, you're answering the question. But >> yeah,
you wouldn't you just ignore them until they kind of extinguish
themselves >> or get bored and move on to a new >> Yeah,
I think the but >> which again
I essentially did. I just I had moved on, right? Like I had not
entirely moved on, but I had I had gone to like I basically knew
docs would drop and I'd read the Destiny stuff then. We had a
whole bunch of other drama we were doing. He decided to start
picking fights with the Discord. I ignored it for a while. He
was just picking fights with the Discord. It was [__]
weird, right? He's been consistently escalating with everybody
he thinks is an op. But the reason why they get bored is because
typically people like that. So like for Kiwi Farms, for instance,
like so my main obsessive guy is Blav, right? He's the guy, my
alter ego who loves me. >> Blav with a B. >> Yeah.
Who? Yeah. And any if I ever reference him in any way, he's always
somehow it's like a victory or he thinks it's like, oh my god,
I live in this guy. But so this is like >> he does live
in he does live in here. you Destiny it Destiny is his head is
occupied so thoroughly by this guy, okay, that Destiny decided
to post additional PII of the minor he was program college
full facial pictures, right? Just to try to mess with this guy,
just to say that this guy's like on disability or something and
this guy's a total loser. That's how much this guy's in Destiny's
head. Okay, like a person who when if I reference them, that's
the only thing that they have to live for. They get that, right?
But the issue now,
this guy actually punched himself in the face so hard he gave
away the fact that he was retaining child that he did a minor,
right? He did that all at the this BL guy and he goes and this
Blav guy, he's the only thing he lives for is like is me referencing
him. You have engaged, encouraged, and like fostered this relationship
from moment one. I I don't know how you can look at this guy
and consider him anything but you. you guys like like he is at
least at your level and you lost like you lost. You are the guy
who docks the minor you were to this this dude so he could prove
it and you're like a laughing stock now. How could you possibly
rewrite this is that guy's the loser. >> I don't know why
this happens. Maybe it does in right leaning spaces. I don't
think but for some reason on the left maybe it's not even the
left. It's just which is by the way unfortunat
seems like a pretty bad guy in that docks people who are members
of my community. That's pretty. That's obviously bad. We obviously
disavow. We hate that. Why Destiny would hand this guy a massive
win is beyond me, beyond my understand. >> For some reason,
the network of leftist socialist comm content creators started
to funnel a lot of this weird snarky stuff and it's it's propagated
up to the highest levels of content. Oh, I think this is a weird
projection again, right? Because this is what Destiny tried to
do when he supported my channel in the beginning, right? Supported
my channel and then a bunch of people who were in his community
and hated Hassan would just feed me like clips of Hassan, right?
I could just do infinite Hassan content to like a thousand viewers
and make a money.
Why? He's describing something that literally was he supported
via my channel before he'd gone to anyone else. If you want to
call it start content, I call it drama content. I didn't go crazy
on Hassan. I'd never dox anybody around Hassan, right? But like
he literally tried to do this. He describes it in his when he
does his whole skits mind map. He talks about how like I used
to have tools for dealing with this and now I don't have tools
for dealing with this anymore. Right. Yes. Yes. He's explained
it multiple times. Frugals. Yes. Right. Such that that guy Blab
who only used to get attention from if I would give him attention
is the only thing she's getting like 2 years ago now Hassan is
reading his posts about me on his >> Who read the post
first? Who mentioned him first? We all put that. We all had that
as off limits until Destiny started referencing this guy regularly.
Destiny started referencing this guy regularly and then we're
like, I guess I guess that's like rules the game now. I guess
we can just do that, right?
Jacob, if I'm not mistaken, didn't he bring this up when he was
like trying to on Zoe when he was on a Darius stream? Didn't
he bring this name up? I feel like he's brought this name up
so many times and a bunch of us were like, well, we don't want
to reference anything in the thread. And like at this point it's
like oh well I guess if he's going to put it out there if he's
gonna read pages from his thread. None of the rest of us do that.
We really don't. I guess Hassan started way at the end but I
just I don't understand how he can like not take into account
his own behavior when he says these things. >> Isn't that
because he's using but Hassan is using Blav as a weapon against
you?
>> So that means that now it how how does Connor take this
victim narrative
How does How is this that he he could possibly take this seriously?
Destiny's the person who engaged with this guy, who went back
and forth with this guy, who tried to amp this guy up as much
as he could, right? Destiny is the person who did this for months,
for years, went back and forth with this guy. And then and then
somehow Desi just tells Connor, "Well, now son's weaponizing
this guy against me, brother. You weaponized him against yourself.
It's not just up to the person to ignore the anti-fan to extinguish
anything. Now, everybody on that anti-fan side will go to these
places to get ammunition and then use it against you. Now, even
at that level, I technically I don't give a because it is what
it is. But the problem, the thing that um August tuned me into
this while ago, the thing that I have to consider is that my
fans, they they see those attacks everywhere. And if I don't
respond or say anything or give any kind of like messaging or
anything, then it's basically just like, oh, well, is that true?
Is like cuz Jesse hasn't addressed this or what's going on here?
So, but I don't want to address it head on because I don't want
my stream, like I said, I haven't had an interest in this content
for years. I don't want my whole >> I haven't had an interest,
guys. I haven't had an interest in this content for years.
For years.
Okay. How can he say this? Seriously, bro, you've had how many
albums of screenshots of Discord messages that don't even include
me have you gone through in the past 4 months? I haven't engaged
in this kind of content in years. He can just sit here and like
transparently lie. It's It's crazy that he can do this and just
Well, I sorry it's not crazy here. It's obvious Conor's the only
one watching and nobody will call him out on it. But it's just
like it's weird. It's sad. It's goofy. >> To be like, "Well,
here's what Jessica and all these people said about me today.
So, we're going to talk about blah blah blah blah blah." Right.
So, >> he didn't when I wasn't talking about him, he decided
that he had to go get screenshots from my discord of people talking
about him. I like talk to somebody like food shops or if I pop
in every now and then or if I just like chat with this person
then this is a person who can like talk and then other people
like kind of orbit them and like chat and at least like in the
discords and everything when you've got the weirdo creep like
uh Duby and all these other guys running around and trying to
like talk [__] and say weird [__] now
they're at least people dude they're not talking saying weird
they're relaying factual information about you that you basically
lie to people and say is unproven or unknown or just a rumor
Right. These guys will go, "No, no, no, no. That's a lie. That's
just Destiny lying. He's just making things up." Right? That's
it. Who understand? Oh, well, this is what's true. This is what
we can argue about fight. Yeah. >> The the right-wing I
just want to clarify something that I think that I've observed
though is with the right-wing there are their version of snarkers
in my opinion. >> Yeah. But everybody hate like Milo. Everybody
hates Milo >> or uh Kino Casino as an example. >> I
wouldn't even say them rightwing are they? These are just like
crazy people. I don't think >> Worski is not rightwing.
>> I feel like they hang out with right-wingers, right?
Doesn't didn't Warskey used to hang out with
>> I don't know if I would consider those guys right even
wors
rightwing.
>> Oh, he maybe he just doesn't know that Warski is on
Kino Casino. >> I don't think so. They're not like >> Oh,
Ethan Ralph's also not rightwing. Okay. Yeah, I would say so.
>> Okay. Okay. Yeah. >> Uh well, all right. So,
if I
understood them to be right-wing, I think it's just because I've
heard them using it, the fs
>> etc., etc. Uh, but the what I would say is that like
those snarker
uh communities or those critic communities or those ALOG communities
or whatever, they seem to be like they seem to just like make
content and then like move on. Move on. You know what I'm saying?
Where they'll cover the drama of the day and then they'll move
on. >> Sure. whereas um I don't think that I've seen them
get wrapped up with a single character that they wanted to mean
to >> Yeah. Uh this is just totally wrong. Okay. Look at
what happened with Rakita.
Are we going to argue that people didn't do this with Rakita
and take every tiny tidbit that ever came out about Rakita and
just drive that [__] to the ground? By the way, Rakita
not directly fighting back against these people ever. Destiny,
any tiny thing that comes out about me or anyone I'm around,
Destiny immediately covers that. I like this is not the same
thing. There is like an equal like back and forth that goes on
with uh with Destiny that I don't think it was existing in in
those other snark communities either. Yes, he did. Okay. Oh,
you know what? Rakita did go back and forth with like his KF
thread now that I think about it. Uh Anaubs.
Yeah, I feel like there's a bunch of these examples. Yeah, but
there's two things going on there. one, if you're getting referenced
by those types of people, you just wouldn't respond to them.
So, they would they wouldn't respond to you and then it would
just move on. But two, those guys aren't getting amplified by
anybody. Like, imagine if the Kino Casino did a show and then
Charlie Kirk was like quote tweeting it. Yes, those guys would
hit that topic way more cuz >> he was Was Destiny not like
actually saying that Queen and I should be Was he not saying
that before Hassan had ever come close to this? Like beyond just
the initial like outcry? I could have sworn that Desi was talking
about us, getting us way before there was ever the other elements
of this conspiracy going on. >> Now they know that they're
getting a huge stream of rewards for it, >> right? He was
talking about doxing us. He's talking about trying to get us
killed way before this other element of the conspiracy comes
in that he now >> So now like >> I don't think there's
an amplification on the right now. >> No, I don't think
there Well, I just they just don't do that kind of content for
whatever reason. I don't know why. >> Yeah. Well, this
is also only ever done to like enforce this isn't like a even
though it's like a certain political groupish that's doing it.
It's it's all like social behavior. Um it's not really political
like just to go a 180 on every political position if it means
opposing me. Like he was defending Taylor Lorent yesterday and
he's defending Taylor Ren today. That's crazy. But it's just
because it's to like attack me, you know? Dude, this is actually,
now that I think about this, this is actually just taking the
concept of lull cows and pretending that that doesn't exist.
The concept of a lowc is that you are going to run that [__]
into the ground, right? That's like exactly what a loca is.
And Destiny is a local. Yes, Destiny is a massive lowc like there
is no more you do not get more peak loc than doxing the minor
you
so everybody can laugh at you for holding out a child. Okay,
that doesn't get any any pe there's no other there's no higher
peak for loadm than that. That is it. That is the peak. So I
don't know if I would even strictly call it political. It just
happened to manifest in all these like left-leaning political
spaces. >> Well, okay. So So just to we we already articulated
the lolli perspective differences between our perspectives. Then
we also articulated like the I I would never use food shops.
Mhm. >> Um the part of the reason why though what what
I'm afraid of um and this is what I articulated to Chud is that
um I feel like by normalizing her by raiding her by granting
her some level of success within the >> let's also let's
just say like me chatting with food shops cuz using it's not
like I've got this
>> but you showed up on chat you you know rated her and
and by the way u you know this is the only compliment that I
will give food chops is uh she had like she stayed she got raided
or whatever and I think she was at like 700 or 800. She maintained
her number because she was being she was talking about JTO she
was talking about Gleman >> and then as a result the drama
content was good enough that she didn't drop like a rock. >> She
kept those people. But my my problem or my fear is that uh you
know she did it as a joke and I understand it's a >> She
does the uh what do you call it?
Unless I've missed some like really funny food shops moments,
it's just that she's doing the propaganda they want, right? There's
just an there is a there is a like need for somebody to feed
them the idea that Destiny isn't like a totally immoral piece
of food shops is the only one the the avowed lollycon small P
is the only person who's willing to take that up. Tom Fuller
is not willing to take that up, right? He's not willing to take
that up anymore. There is nobody else. But there's an appetite
for anybody who will help them cope.
So yes, yes, they will stay there. The the most degenerate cultists
will stay there. Absolutely. >> But the tweet was like,
"Oh, now that I have some level of viewership, I'm going to start
trying to normalize my ideas in reference to, you know, lollycon
or whatever." And so for me, I think that there's probably a
few lost souls in >> There might be >> who your permissive
attitude and they're going to hear her apologia >> on the
other side of that coin. Uh,
okay. when I when I just cover the chorus stuff. Is that the
other side of the coin? I don't think it is. That's been most
of my content the past two >> Men's apologia and then they're
just going to be like, "Yeah, >> I don't care anywhere
near enough about the LA issue to give a about that." I think
if I had a stronger position on it, like if I found out that
they were like kids or whatever, then I would be like, "Okay,
this is probably not a person I want to be with." But I just
don't care about that issue. >> Yeah. And it's not like
there's any >> If there are other people, I guess, that
I can chat with, then maybe. Not yet. Not yet. >> Um, it's
a that's a rough world. You know, you've experienced
lost souls. So, why would we allow people to fall into that?
>> I don't think I don't think Connor considers, by the
way, Destiny keeps saying, "Connor, you know, you've experienced
this harassment." I don't think Connor sees this as harassment.
I think Connor just sees this like the way things are online
and he's like kind of fine with it. He might not like some of
the stuff I say at this point, but >> Rean Rubin donated
$3. Destiny never apologizes for the smell. He just sits there
being a stinker. >> Thank you very much for the three.
Appreciate you, buddy. >> A trap. >> No, I mean that
like it's a rough world in terms of like um the weird Discord
people that like those communities are just like very very active.
Um like >> and they're cannibalistic. >> Yeah. Like
I love him to death, but Pisco will be 100% bought into those
communities in 6 months. Like guaranteed he will be >> what
into the hate communities. >> Absolutely 100%. cuz Aaron
is fully one trillion% bought in and all those people are constantly
in peace go's chat and in his discords and everything else. >> Uh
I've just shown like dude all I have to show is like the you
say to like anyone like I I don't know I don't have to convince
anybody but when I do when somebody comes to me okay somebody
says like I think you're like way out to lunch on this. All I
have to do is go show your like kick logs of you like trying
to taunt one of your victims, your non-consensual recording,
right? That's all I have to show someone and they're immediately
like, "Oh, this guy is actually a total piece of shit." You're
actually right.
All I have to show is you talking [__] about the
silly serious, right? And how that's changed Pisco's views. That's
all I would have to show. Now, Pisco doesn't talk to me except
today on Twitter. Oh my god. But Pisco doesn't really talk to
me. We have no DMs or anything, unfortunately. Unfortunately,
one day, one day I'll rebuild the Pisco Bridge. Okay, one day.
>> okay. I have I have higher faith for Pisco because I'm
hoping that his rooting in the legal world and his rooting, and
by the way, in his content, as at least as far as I've seen with
the the titling that he's done over the past week, he's almost
ignored the Ethan Klein versus U drama, he's almost exclusively
been talking about like mainstream news events. >> Okay.
I hope I'm wrong. We'll Well, I hope I'm right, but um yeah,
like you're right, too.
>> Pisco doesn't want to do drama content. He's never wanted
to do drama content. When has Pisco ever done drama content?
I don't see him doing that. I see him doing entirely political
content all the >> It's just it's a lot of pressure. There's
a lot. >> Well, it is a lot of pressure. It's you know
when you have half a dozen to a dozen people coming in and being
like disavow disavow you're a [__] piece
>> this isn't but this isn't like this is Fitz's wheelhouse,
right? Teeny tiny Tony. like he is a sorry I shouldn't say just
political he's also like trying to do law tube stuff like he
talks to a lot of the law tubers that was big law tube content
right but I don't think he just does drama he's not just doing
people talking each other and I think the basically the only
way I saw him engage with the H3 stuff was via the lawsuit excuse
me hanging out with this person he's hanging out with that person
yeah it's a lot of pressure um but the but I could see why a
tactic that some people will use is they're just going going
to focus on dry politics because they're going to starve the
drama frogs in their community. Although, weirdly enough, sorry
to bring you up, Hutch, but Hutch. Um, I see Hutch constantly
getting attacked and I don't think he's really done much of the
drama at all.
I mean, correct me if I'm wrong, but I >> see somebody
who >> Hutch is just a really imprecise guy and Hutch Hutch
is like a That's a really nice way of saying Hutch is just like
a who says things and then people attack the things he says.
I'm sorry. Like Hutch is kind of just loads a lot of the screenshots
in the communities and I think Egyptical talked about it on a
stream. Um Hutch made some comment uh it was when I was in DC
I listened where he said something like oh like Destiny can be
rehabilitated in 5 years or something. I heard I got really nerv
what the do you even know like it's just that felt so >> I
did cover it from a positive point of view. I literally was totally
charitable to Hutch in that case >> and then I think I
said something on stream maybe I said it to you down here but
I think I said something on stream was like that was just a I
don't know whatever. Um, but then afterwards, I think Hutch on
his stream said something like, "Oh, like I wasn't thinking too
much when I said that or whatever." When he made that comment,
uh, Joistical Quean and then, uh, I don't think Spicy Chat did,
but Kiwi Farms tuned into Hutch and then a lot of them shifted
on that because they're like, "We need a full disaval from Hutch."
Although that's receded a bit because now they're focused on
you and lately Wick um, in order to try to like tell you guys
you're never allowed to talk to me and then and now Hutch is
just fighting like the kind of mainstream lefty political. I
was about to say we we that's actually probably fairly easy transition
is the Taylor Lauren story, but I don't think we're there yet.
>> Um the I hear what you're saying. >> Mhm. Hutch
gets a lot of like main um not main he gets a lot of like actual
political fighting. It's not just like this weird alt community
that's like kind of hanging off me. Yeah. >> they they
focus on for a little bit but not too much. Yeah. >> So,
if I if I could though, if I could snap my fingers, >> he
watches you so much. Uh, there's a big incentive to watch my
stuff and figure out how to argue that like I am the things that
Destiny has said. I guess there's like a big incentive for this.
I don't know. It's just it's >> Just like this weird alt
community that's like kind of hanging off me. >> they they
focus on for a little bit but not too much. Yeah. So, if I if
I could though, if I could snap my fingers and I could uh resolve
the Pixie situation, resolve the JSTO Sherry situation, resolve
the
um
all these situations. If I could resolve all this stuff, I would.
And then I would be trying to focus on like I I hate to say it,
people are going to make fun of me for it, but that's okay. I'd
be trying to focus on like what PV was trying to do, which was
effectively taking the energy of Twitch and YouTube politics,
carving off 2 to 5% of it for canvasing operations, phone calls,
and volunteer organizations. I wanted to do disaster relief,
but that's not uh nobody's really interested in that yet. >> But
the whole point of it is like at the end of the day, Twitch and
YouTube politics is a bunch of nerds who there's hundreds of
thousands if not millions of dollars in Twitch and YouTube's
YouTube politics. There's hundreds of thousands of people. Um
the canvasing operations were the one thing that seemed to actually
be like positive and real as a result of this besides charities
I >> Yeah, I agree. >> Um so that should be the job.
>> I agree 100 trillion%. Yeah. >> I mean that's
what I was kind of angled at at the end of last year, right?
With the studio in New York and interviewing like people and
>> trying to do like >> Wonder if anything changed
since last year that's made him totally radioactive to any serious
political actor. I wonder if there's like things that have happened
in the past month that have made him even more radioactive to
every single person in these spheres.
Justifiably so.
>> Yeah, that was the angle. Yeah. >> Okay. But then
that's that's the problem though is we keep getting wrapped in
the um which is funny. I'm not I'm not going to like I obviously
watch the drama content, but if we keep >> Never mind.
>> Sorry. Go ahead. >> No, you said it was funny.
Go ahead. I was making asy joke. You're good. the but but the
point is though um they're
>> yeah Conor's a obviously
Connor thinks Connor is just on the page by the way Andrew Wilson's
on the same page they're basically on the same page as Wes they're
like anybody who was willing to engage in any consensual relationship
with Destiny should have known that they would get raped that
like like he is such a degenerate piece of they should have just
known that their consent would be violated that's what Connor
believes like 100% that's Connor that's Andrew Wilson that's
like Wes that like if you engage with this guy at all, you should
know he is such an obvious piece of [__] that like,
you know, your consent would be violated. That how he manages
to transfer that condemnation that he should have for Destiny
onto Destiny's victims, that's like a it's a gymnastics act I
can't describe. I can't understand, but even minors uh >> organizations.
So, for instance, I don't know if they're going to want me to
bring up their name, but effectively >> Don't do that.
>> Don't do that. >> Probably not.
>> Never mind. >> Sorry. Go ahead. >> No, you
said it was funny. Go ahead. I was making joke. You're good.
>> The But but the point is though, um there there are
organizations. So for instance, I don't know if they're going
to want me to bring up their name, but effectively like >> don't
do that. >> Don't do that. >> Probably not. >> Probably
not. I think they told me to.
>> All right. >> What? I don't know what you're going
to >> I know what I'm going to say, which is it's a >> the
manboy association. >> Oh, yeah. >> No, I'm just
kidding.
>> No, what I was going to say is that there's like Okay.
Number one, uh I don't know if PB is doing anything for midterms.
Number two, um the uh the national ground game and so >> so
this is America. >> National ground game is I met Z Cohen
Sanchez in DC and she's trying to get Democrat donors to back
her project and what she wants to do is she wants to
>> um Turning Points USA but for the Democrats and so that's
what she's trying to do. And so for me, uh, taking Twitch and
YouTube politics energy.
>> Hey, Connor. Uh, you're going to go talk to Destiny
about rating this person, this like lollycon person. They like
drawing pictures of kids. They've stated, uh, that they desire
to have a 12-year-old wrapped around their waist that you're
going to go talk about that. And then what I want you to do right
after that is bring up National Ground Game, bring up on America.
I want you to hard tie the name Z. Cohen Sanchez to Steven Bennell
and all the things Steven Bennell does. If you could do that
for me, Connor, I would
love that. Thank you very much, Connor. I appreciate it, buddy.
I appreciate you >> starting uh mirror chapters to the
Republicans with Democrats.
>> Creating cool debate events and then having Twitch and
YouTube political content show up for debate events and canvasing
operations. That's the next >> Yeah, I agree. I think Yeah,
I think it's a cool project. It's the reason I did stuff with
them before. Yeah. >> Okay. Well, >> it's like related
to the America stuff kind of, right? >> Okay. Okay. So,
so how is it even possible though to like divorce Twitch and
YouTube politics away from this and move into the real stuff
or is it just >> No, it's not possible because unfortunately
Counter Boys, if you had any empathy, it's not possible because
all of you guys
are involved.
He he literally a bunch of the people who have had their consent
violated are people who were involved in his community or in
his political. That's that's before, by the way. That's before
the child stuff, okay? Which is obviously standing on its own
is something different. Uh if he hadn't used his community to
find these people, then maybe you have like a different conversation,
but there's no reason when there are all these other people who
could be involved in this. There's no reason to have Destiny
involved in this. You just there's just no reason. >> I
would say there's one way to do it. >> Um but I mean it's
I guess it's easy and convenient for me to say it, but like people
just have to ignore it. But people are not capable of doing that
right now because there's so much pressure from these people
and people feel like they have to have a position on it or they
have to respond to it or they have to do something. Like I give
a lot of props to I give props to you and I give a lot of props
to Wick for resisting a lot of it. But it's really hard when
you've got like Z that Z's been doxed on QB farms. People are
spreading all of her [__] around. I've had like I've
seen three of my fans get doxed in the last two weeks. People
who just like tweet and people like found their names and then
are like posting their jobs and [__] One of the guys
emailed me and said call the cops. So I like that's I mean like
>> well I mean I called the cops within the past week and
it wasn't even that I got like specific threats or whatever but
I called my local law enforcement and I just said hey everybody's
like we're effectively in a doxing war right now. >> Yeah.
It's it's amazing. I'm sitting here. Okay. I'm basically like
Greenland. I'm like incapable of off I don't have like the ability
to do any of this. Right. And I'm being told I'm in a doxy war
and like America is missiles at me and I'm like no I didn't I
can't do anything. What are you what's happening? And then a
bunch of the people in like Europe who are supposed to have my
back and like be at the UN, they're just like, "Well, America
said this is happening." And uh yeah, it's just a doxing war.
I don't know what to tell you, buddy. I don't know what to I
don't know. Yeah, sorry. You're just going to get hit with these
missiles now. I'm like, "What the I didn't do." I ker I don't
have any idea. I assume if they're talking about people getting
docked or something, he says Kiwi Farms, I assume it's anonymous
people on Kiwi Farms who I have no control over or connection
to. And trust me, in terms of, hey, if they had some interventions,
they're like, hey, if you uh if you could just not show people
on stream or if you could like do this, I'd be willing to to
take into account, oh, maybe this happening and maybe I should
be a little more um what do you call it? Like a little more careful
not to make people targets or I could understand that maybe,
right? But what I'm not willing to do is drop all of these topics
or like stop talking about anything that's important to me because
Kiwi Farms is doing something. I'm not going to let that element
of it control me. Okay, if there's like a concern that like,
oh, a couple of my chatters are docks or something, if I felt
like I could do something to take pressure off of those people
without compromising my opinion at all, I'd absolutely do that,
right? I'm absolutely willing to do that, right? But it depends,
okay? Because if you're if you're one of the people who is a
Destiny Chatter who's like trying to spread what they think is
docs of me and I'm like annoyed with you or I I like point that
out on stream that you're like trying to dox people, like I don't
know what to tell you. I don't think I should not cover that
either, right? So, it would all just depend on how this going.
Anyway, I don't I don't control things. If I felt like my stream
was a vehicle for this in some way, if I felt that, I would probably
take precautions against that. So, we'll see cuz I've been told
that apparently there's some argument here that like uh I brought
up a chatter and they got doxed or something, which uh if that
happened, I would have to take appropriate measures. If somebody
was going to target people I was just annoyed with or something,
I'd have to think about something there, right? I don't that
doesn't put blame on me. By the way, if I'm if I'm like calling
out some justifi justifiable to call out behavior, I'm not going
to say that's my fault that something bad happened to that person.
Okay. What I'm saying is if I felt like, oh well, I shouldn't
show this on stream or I need to censor names or something. Maybe
there's some some consideration there, right? Is a reason he
just says that he doesn't show proof. Oh, I would think I'm saying
if I could see some proof of this happening, then I'd be interested.
Uh I would consider it. But if it's just like oh uh if it's just
by the way I'm just gonna say no I'm not saying you didn't say
it was from our community. I'm saying if it was KF or something
creger but like what I won't do is I'm not going to like not
cover Destiny's or something. I'm not going to like I'm not going
to sacrifice my coverage or change my opinion to protect people
who are engaging in like
like conduct, right? I'm not going to do that. I I can't control
Kiwi Farms. I don't have that ability. I have zero ability to
do that. Right. And the people on there who've been doxing people,
I have zero ability because all the people who dox people close
to Destiny have been doing that since way before I was against
Destiny. Okay. The fear I had of Kiwi Farms in December of 2024
was that they would dox me for being a fan of Destiny, for being
like close to Destiny. Okay.
But almost everybody who's been doxed around Destiny was doxed
before that point. So that's that's all I'm saying is like this
this force has been doing it
regardless of who's covering Destiny negatively regardless of
what what's been going on. They've been doing that for a while
now. To put that on me or to put it on Queen or to put it on
anybody is insane.
Why these people don't harass me anymore and it's cuz I don't
care and I don't give them attention. Uh but if they find that
they have some
>> Bro, are you serious? Cuz I don't give them attention.
Guys, it's just it's just because I don't give them any attention
at all. Okay, I don't give them any attention.
Oh, hold on. Where's my thing? Oh, hold on. Where is it? Here.
Occurred. Just go to my Twitter. I'm going to go find the the
of him with Rose. And I'm just going to pull it up again. I don't
give them attention. He says he says he doesn't give them attention.
You just go down to the tweet. Where's the tweet at? Where's
the tweet at? Not that one. I'll find it. I'll find it. There
we go. There we go. Right. I don't give any attention to this.
While he posts PII, fullfaced pictures, the College of Rose,
all of this,
fully engages with Kiwi Farms. Kiwi Farm's ability to investigate
anything is super pathetic. He's taunting them directly, right?
I don't, guys, I don't engage with these people at all. So, when
I don't engage, they'll go after the people around me. Shut the
up. It's so crazy. Oh, whoops. This is a Willy Mac video. Let's
No, that's not it either. What did I Hold on. Did I just Did
I really do that? No the where did I just shift off of this window
right here. Thank you. >> All you maybe
hold on. Where was this me? We're somewhere around here. >> We'll
just have to ignore it. But people are not capable of doing that
right now cuz there's so much pressure from these people and
people feel like they have to have a position. And by the way,
I don't give a like at these
drama farmers. But then for me, I'm worried that actually >> behavior
don't do it again. Like I think it's the easiest thing in the
world. we get some kind of like pragmatic result out of it or
maybe >> I for some reason clicked off of this window.
I don't know why I did this. >> But you don't let enemies
try to like weaponize these, >> but it's water off a >> they
have some success in other outlets. People don't harass me anymore
cuz I don't care and I don't give them attention. Uh but if they
find that they have some success in other outlets, as soon as
they see any success there, that's what they lean into. But like
notice right now, you'll never see somebody approach uh like
nobody talks about Trump's cases, his
>> nobody talks about like the Tates to any of these conservative
guys because they know cuz why? Well, I mean like even >> I
do. But it's water off a duck. >> Exactly. Yeah. Cuz they
don't give a [__] about it. They don't care, right?
>> Interviewing the Tates was insane. >> Why won't
you guys just let me be a predator like the conservatives let
Andrew Tate do? Why won't you guys just let ignore me keeping
child on my hard drives like you like everybody lets conservatives
do? Why won't you just let
Okay, let him He makes these arguments like totally unapologetically
totally just with no no introspection, no thought, he'll just
make these >> Yeah. So, I think that like we should have
our own like moral standards or whatever, but like those are
things that you hold yourself to account to and then other people
who you Hold on. Are the people who you care about who are near
you like hold you to account to these? But you don't let enemies
try to like weaponize these against you, which is what happens.
And it works so well cuz so many people get you the the reason
why enemies quote unquote talk about this stuff is because you
lie about it. You lie and and defame people and you lie and harass
people. Like you can't stop lying. Let's not forget he fully
confessed to non-consensually sending Pixie tapes to this 17-year-old.
He totally confessed to straight away that he did it non-consensually
and he just lies and says, "No, no, no. That's not what I meant.
I just meant like I was, you know, I was sad it leaked. That's
all I meant, guys." He just lies. So, yes, if you're just going
to lie and harm people all the way along, then yeah, third parties
have to come in. It's not just, "Oh, well, my loved ones won't
hold me accountable." Turns out the only people you let into
your inner circle are complete and utter sick offenses. Anybody
who was in a total sick event has left. every other person held
you accountable by walking away from you. We got so caught up
in it. >> My question though because obviously um I'm feeling
pressure from a variety of sources and by the way I don't give
a like at the so so yeah to some degree I obviously care like
the I talk to these people in DMs or in replies and um it's not
nice when people call you bad names on the internet. Um however
ultimately I still have a life outside of this [__]
>> Sure. Not to trivialize though. It's not just that.
It's like spam calls to people's jobs and >> a lot of other
people have experience worship than me. >> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Um but but the point is though, how do you know that?
Because when you're so for instance like Benny Johnson or whatever
or um you've talked >> uh no anemone Dan's still like around
in chat and stuff. Okay. He just doesn't want the rep of hanging
out with the child guy. >> That's all. He's just trying
to avoid that rep as best he can. He's totally friends with Destiny.
He's got no problem with Destiny or any of his conduct, right?
Otherwise, he would have made a statement. Destiny said that
Dan has no problem with what he did. And Dan's never contradicted
that. So, I don't know how you could possibly assume Dan has
any problem with it. >> Talk to him. The Hodge Twins. >> So,
the Hodge Twins talked to Andrew Tate in my opinion and Benny
Johnson talked to Andrew Tate number one because they knew that
they would get the clout, influence, money, etc., but also because
they knew that they would trigger the lips. And so, principles
didn't matter ultimately because they were going to stick by
their team. not because it was good to stick by their team
but because
uh they knew that they would get some kind of like pragmatic
result out of it. So I guess my question is how do you how do
you balance
uh calling out moral failures of people and also allowing like
descriptive reality to exist along with not allowing political
projects to die because you're getting sucked into the drama
>> trivially easy thing to do. I don't think it's a >> like
what? It's trivially easy. How? >> Trivially easy. You
tell somebody like, "Oh, I think hey what >> you just tell
somebody. If you think somebody [__] up, they say,
"Hey, I think you [__] up." Like, change this behavior.
Don't do it again. Like, I think it's the easiest thing in the
>> Uh, how many times can Destiny nonconensually share
videos before other people just go, you know what? I don't think
you're learning this lesson or content, nudes, actual poor. How
many times can he do this before it's like, "Oh, no. You're actually
you're actually not helpable. You actually could keep doing it
world to do. >> Okay. But what if what if we disagree on
something? So for instance, like I >> we can have disagreements.
If there is a disagreement where like the moral disagreement
is so huge >> that you like I can't I don't think I can
be a part of this then you separate. But like I mean every movement
is going to have people who have like fundamental moral disagreements.
That happens. But there are going to be some things that you
draw the line around where it's like this is too much. Like I
can't like this person might be pro-choice and this person might
be pro- life. Generally speaking, depending on these people can
probably work together, but if a guy was like pro murderer or
this guy was like pro like there are some things where it's like
this is like a bridge to where I can't on that. Yeah. >> But
I I'll tell you just you know face to face that that line for
me is almost hit by food shops and the reason why is because
like so
>> almost almost. >> So I get it like um pragmatic
reasons you're using I keep saying this you're not saying this.
comes. Uh guys, we're uh we're coming up on the 2hour mark left
on the stream. Been going for a couple hours here. We just crossed
the 4 hour mark on the stream. If you guys like the content,
I want you to go ahead and follow on every platform. Follow on
axe. Follow on Twitch. Join the Discord.
Join the Discord right now. Okay? Join, join, join. And if you
really like the content, you want the content to go on for longer,
you can donate, guys. There's a couple ways you can do that.
You can sub on kick. You can sub on Twitch. You can give subs
on kick. Subbing on kick is the best way to sub. Okay. 955 split
on kick. It's the best. All right. Twitch is 50/50. Kick is 955.
95 going to me. All right.
You can also buy a TTS message. Buy a TTS message through Kickbot.
Buy a TTS message through Streamlabs. All right. All dollars
donated these ways goes towards more time on the stream. We are
about uh let's say seven subs away from another hour on the stream.
Appreciate all the support, guys. What's the split on Patreon?
It's not that great, but I still appreciate the Patreon most
of all, okay? Cuz the Patreon's on a different thing, guys. Last
but not least, there's the Patreon.
If you want to help, you know, fight against perspective future
homelessness. There's a couple different tiers over on the Patreon.
There's the $5 tier. This gets you, I think, soundboards in the
Discord and some some different priority things in the Discord.
$25 tier is for additional content that will materialize one
one day, okay? At some point in the in the near near future.
All right, guys. $100 tier. Do not sign up for this tier unless
you have unless you earn more than six figures a month. Okay,
but there's a couple different tiers of the Patreon. All right,
I appreciate all of the Patreon members. 35 an hour is the current
I think it's 45 an hour is the current rate. 45 per hour.
Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. First first two hours are 30 each. All
right. Some comedic relief. Hold on. Some comedic relief. Quick
pallet cleanser with the with the Shuvi guy. We're going to get
back to the Connor conversation in just a second, guys. Is this
just the Hold on. Is this going to be >> What the dude
metal? >> Oh, this is really Shuy. Really, Shuy?
>> I'm the joke.
>> Dude, get somebody at kick needs to get Shuy like a
like a hardware show, okay? Of him just building. Him just being
Macgyver and building [__] This is awesome content
every single time. Okay.
What the [__] dude? Metal just sprayed in my face,
bro. I don't even know what to say, dude. >> He literally
hears the drill like kicking around over here or something and
he puts his fingers right where the screws are coming through.
>> What a guy. What a what a guy this guy. >> What
the [__] bro? >> Smart guy this guy.
>> Amazing. Big things happening on guys. Big things. All
right, we're back to the Connor Desty conversation. Let's continue.
Um, you're using her as a weapon against Jto and Queen because
let's face it, she can a log them uh pretty well. So, you're
using her as a weapon against these.
>> What he's actually using food shops as is a like an
IQ check for his community. That's what he's actually he I can't
believe that he doesn't see this that like by sending people
over there, he's like only filtering down to the worst most useless
cultists, right? Like she is an embarrassing person. She is not
capable of making arguments. Zip Zip is an embarrassing person.
You've surrounded yourself with total re and like I got to imagine
if there was anybody left who had some intelligence, who had
some like interesting opinions, who was going to be of use to
you in some way in the future, they've got to see the Zip Zip
and Food Shop show and just go like, uh, no, no, no thanks. Not
just his audience, for Connor too, to further humiliate Connor
is possible. is drama farmers. But then for me, I'm worried that
actually unironically that that tweet that she put out as a joke,
which I understand to be a joke, is that she'll get 500 viewers,
thousand viewers, whatever, and then she'll normalize that viewership
within her community, and there'll be half a dozen to a few dozen
souls who will just fall into what I view as like a spiritual
trap,
uh, which is being a lollyconer.
I think that's unironically a spiritual
I think it's hell.
>> So, I don't want people to go into hell.
>> So, how do we stop that? >> I I don't know argue
against today. I don't I just don't have that huge of a position
on it that I cared as much about it. >> But, I mean, if
I did, then maybe I would feel stronger about it. I think if
it was a larger part of her content, I'm going to be honest,
I've never actually >> Actually, I think I did hear her
argue about this. I think like a year ago, that's why I removed
it from cuz I just didn't want to whatever. >> Two years
ago. >> Yeah. But it's like if it was like every day it
was like here's the 30 minute you know lolli praise preaching
segment. I'd be like okay this is kind of weird. I think this
is too much. Then I probably you know I think I'm good on that
one. But I I don't know maybe this is maybe this was a or is
a big part of the content. I've just never seen it before. >> well
I haven't seen it recently. Uh to be honest I I think what what
ended up happening or at least been pointed out to me by people
is the fact that two years ago in my opinion it was a large part
of the content. >> I freaked out and yelled at Chud and
then they're like why aren't you yelling at Stephen?
So, >> this is that conversation, >> but I'm not
I'm not pro lolly and I don't support Lolly in my community.
>> I know, but >> I don't have people posting LOI.
That's not in any of my That would always be against the rules
every rhyme at. >> But it's like, >> wait, why did
movies get banned in EG again? Can someone does anyone know why
movies got banned in DG? Does anybody remember any knowowers?
Any knowowers participating in the knowers, noticers? Anyone?
the the raid, then the watching the drama content, and then >> now
I will say they handled that appropriately by being like, "Okay,
[__] stop."
But I'm just saying >> building a platform and then maybe
fall some people fall into her perspective. So, it's like a three
consequence
>> Yeah. Nobody their side is never following that. I would
never kneecap my side by having to >> wait wait
and then the raid then the watching the drama content and then
build >> Wait one wait hold on one second >> and
yelled at Chud and then they're like why aren't you yelling at
Steven so >> this is that conversation >> but I'm
I'm not I'm not pro lolly and I don't spot lolly in my community
>> I know but >> like I don't have people posting
lolli that's not in any of my [__] that would always
be against the rules every rhyme I'm at >> but it's like
the the raid then the watching the drama content and then building
a platform and
how do I say this? Someone was delivering food and uh and Cherry
went to the door and she didn't recognize or she she didn't see
that the guy was there. She just saw like the ding had happened
and he was like standing there apparently spooked her. I don't
know if you guys even heard she kind of yelled. Sorry if you're
wondering. I was like what the they found us.
>> They didn't find us. and then maybe fall some people
fall into her perspective. So, it's like a three
>> I hope you guys didn't hear that one. >> Jesus
consequence. >> Sorry, I have to actually listen to what
Connor is saying here. I do want to hear >> I I have to
listen. >> I'm not pro lolly and I don't lolly in my community.
>> We're locked in. >> I know, but >> I don't
have people posting lolly. That's not in any of my [__]
That would always be against the rules ever. >> But it's
like the the raid then the watching the drama content and then
building a platform and then maybe follow some people. him acting
like this is no big deal. I'm fine with him acting like it's
no big deal. Uh he's just being honest. He doesn't care, right?
I think I think the like total disengagement with um how Connor
feels about this like and mocking him for it. I think that's
telling and then uh I don't know like it's basically
reminding Connor over and over again that he's never going to
rise to the moral level of moral character that Connor wants
him to. And the his entire Connor<unk>'s entire pursuit
is like worthless here. fall into her perspective. So, it's like
a three consequence series. >> Yeah. Nobody their side
is never following that. I would never kneecap my side by having
to have them weaponize all of those principles. And Chloe was
jerking it to some 15-year-old. He was a long time ago anyway.
So, who the [__] >> I have to defend his honor.
She was 17 and she lied about her age. >> Oh, that mattered
for Chud, didn't it? Wasn't there one other
uh did Chud get from that girl and then keep that after he'd
heard that she was under the age of 18? >> Did Chud do
that? I'm just curious. I I forget if I missed it. Did Chud do
that? >> Other big streamer that came out and defended
him on that? >> Yes.
Truth. Huh? >> Yeah. Well, okay. It was Xanderhal.
>> What? No, it was me. >> I know. >> Oh, you
Also, >> Xanderhal was our base defender, our M >> I
know, but Xanderhal unironically defended Chud during that drama
as well. >> So, no. And >> to be clear, I didn't
defend Chud because I thought he was innocent. I just hate 17-year-olds.
>> Right. Okay. Anyways,
so um I think I'm trying to think of how people are looking at
this. No, no, no, no, no. Okay. I think uh I think a lot of people
would have actually if this was the only thing that happened
with Destiny, right? I think a lot of people would have defended
him on this on up until the point where he kept the videos, right?
A lot more people would have. The problem is it's all of this
coming back to back to back to back, right? Like you have the
the actual consent violations, the sending non-consensually,
the recording uh audio non-conensually, you have like all these
things coming like he's losing different cohorts of his audience
with all of these things as they find out about it. Right. Anyway,
>> okay. So the so the point is >> I think people
would have defended him on this to be honest. You're okay. You're
saying that you can call out the bad behavior. >> So, up
until he keeps it after he finds out the age, after he gets an
indication she's a minor >> on your side, when it hits
when it crosses a moral perspective that you can't deal with
anymore, that's when you can separate.
Um, then you said that the real point of Twitch or what should
be the real point of Twitch and YouTube politics should be carving
off two to 5% of the energy, money, time, and attention and putting
it into canvasing events, volunteering, election. >> We
can do more than that. Ideally, I would have liked to funnel
all of my online stuff into kind of like political power oriented
stuff, but obviously that got the brakes pumped on it when little
Miss and her friend decided to go in federal court. So, >> well,
okay, but let's say it's a year from now or two years from now.
Uh, and the distance between you and these issues has expanded.
>> Um, are you going to revive that dream? >> Uh,
yeah. I mean, like I said, now I'm in the tendril planting phase
where I'm reaching out more and building a connections again.
Um, I'll I just have to see what the vibes are in a couple months
or whatever and keep pushing forward. Yeah. Do you think Okay,
but do you think that most people like le let's say that um Jtock
or Cleman are like hey um Stephen is prodoxing doxing me and
they're using a lollycon in order to do >> Self-defense
doxing to be fair, but go >> Okay. Defensive doxing. >> Defensive
doxing. Yeah. >> Okay. So,
that's probably something we that's actually probably the next
topic we should talk about because I feel like we've already
summarized it and so at this point I'm kind of moral frogging.
>> Um so, let's move on from the moral frogging. Defensive
doxing. The other thing that I'm getting called out for is the
fact that I said two or three years ago. It was in reference
to Kevin Cassley who's actually disappeared uh as far as I know.
>> Damn. Did you get docks? >> Um, no. But he was
like a neoliberal guy. I think he was neoliberal. I think he
turned into a Trump sickopant. I forget. But effectively Kevin
Cassley, somebody brought it to my attention that Kevin Cassley
was going out of his way to dock some of his critics. He was
like looking up their personal information and sending it to
them in DMs. And I was like, "Okay, this is super up. You're
basically threatening
over internet beef. This is very dumb. Um, and basically this
should be the line where nobody crosses it. However, excuse me,
the accusations from Jtocking Queen is that you're not engaged
in defensive doxing. You're throwing [__] at the
wall and seeing what sticks.
>> Oh, I've only doxed people that are unhinged and obsessed
about me. I'm pretty sure every person I've done has been one
of those people. Have you done it or have you gotten gay ops
people in DGG or gay ops people in different discords to do it?
>> Combination of both, but if somebody passes out to me,
I'll post it. I don't give a queen. I'm looking for Doobie. Careful.
Um,
what did Doobie do to you? >> The unhinged obsessive weird
workshopping with all these disgusting losers in the background.
I think it's gross and weird. I've seen him type unhinged disgusting
weird about me and like all these um just had more logs to me
sent today about it. What if he thinks you're genuinely >> Can
you give an example?
>> Can you send that to Wick and be like, "Is this a direct
threat now to do?"
>> No, Wick doesn't care. Wick doesn't >> But this
is as direct as it gets. >> Yeah. I mean, he's he I'm I'm
sorry. It was already direct before, but yes, you're right. This
is more direct. This is more pointed. It won't matter.
>> it won't. Dude, if it had any chance of mattering, I
would I would care. Also, I'm not going to be the person who
does it, you know? It's just wild. Listen to Cherry. Guys, I
don't know if you realize this. I'm not going to go around to
people and tell them like, "You have to stop hanging out with
this guy." I already let Connor know when he's a total moral
degenerate. Okay, that's as far as I'm willing to go is just
going like, "Hey, Connor, I think your conscience will kick in
eventually." Right. Eventually. >> I'm looking for >> Yeah,
I know. I know what you're saying, Cherry. I know what you're
saying. >> For Doobie, careful. Um, >> Doobie, who
else? >> We're looking for Doobie. Be careful.
Uh, what is
>> the unhinged obsessive weird uh workshopping with all
these disgusting losers in the background? I think it's gross
and weird. I've seen him type unhinged disgusting weird about
me and like all these um service. I just had more logs to me
sent today about it. >> What if he thinks you're genuinely
evil though? What what like what if Jtock Queen and uh because
this is an argument that I've heard them bring up or whatever.
They're like, "Oh, Stephen thinks that there there's this conspiracy
to take him out, but the conspiracy is the fact that we don't
like him and we think he's a bad guy and he sucks and he should
go down." That's >> If you want to have that if you want
to have that like opinion of me, I think that's fine. But when
it gets to the point where you're obsessively
facilitating conversations about um like my dating partners or
whatever, everybody associated with that, like all those people.
The only person who did that excessively was Kelly Jean and that
is somebody he likes now because she doesn't like me or Cherry.
The only person who's done that was Kelly and he's explicitly
said we don't talk about Kelly anymore. I It's like it's so disingenuous.
He is just so disingenuous all of the time. It's so funny. Well,
by the way, nothing he could do in response to Kelly on his girlfriend
beyond just talking back would be justifiable.
Okay, it's on the internet. Don't be a >> or when you start
like obsessively talking about like my kid. Uh or when you start
obsessively like when you're like reading out like my revenge
or making fun of like stuff >> like I just see this is
the thing is I'm sure this sounds compelling to Connor in some
way, right? I'm sure this could be this could sound compelling
to Connor somehow maybe.
Right. But when he says, "Oh, when you read out my revenge Yeah.
We don't talk about his kid." And then he says, "When you read
out my wrench, he has leaked
DMs with multiple women." He has read out DMs from reviews for
multiple women. He does not believe this is a bar. It only applies
to him. It is it is only a rule when it comes to him. And it's
it's apparently also only really a rule when it comes to him
this minor. That's where it all of a sudden everything changed
on this. Although actually I guess technically when Adavore was
going to out him as a manipulative like evil piece of [__]
he did also do it there right if you if you leak my I might have
some photos of you I'll leak related like leaked on that then
no police I don't give a [__] um >> there's
two things that Stephen actually did show me that I actually
found kind of disturbing today uh number one um somebody who
used to be an orbiter reading out Steven's specific address >> Wait
I showed you this today or >> I think you did >> oh
oh the oh >> uh Lord Don is unhinged Shut. I don't know
why the [__] he do that. That was insane. That was
an insane thing to do. >> Um, yeah. Not justified, by the
way. >> Lauren de Laguna. >> Yeah. Wasane.
>> Although, yeah. No, not justified. Um, I'm trying to
think. Apparently, some happened where Lauren is no longer a
public defender. I I still don't think she'd be justified doing
that to Destiny if she uh suspected he had a hand in that or
something. And she would need some evidence of it. She can't
just go do it. So, >> correct. Specifically >> on
a show. Just says it. Yeah. >> On a show. saying the exact
address, which like for me it's like, okay, you want him to get
harassed, stabbed, shot, murdered, whatever. So that's bananas.
And then number two was the spreadsheet, which is basically >> Oh,
Jesus. Yeah. Don't even Yeah. But yeah, it's just creepy and
weird. It's >> Trying to document all of your friends,
all of your >> like the age of every girl I've ever known.
Yeah. It's weird and creepy. >> And so for me, >> and
these guys like on all these other people, they play into it.
Like I I don't do the um I joked about like the being Dexter,
whatever. These guys all play into it. He just made a massive
statement, right, with no evidence. And Connor doesn't think
to pause and go, "Hey, I should What do you mean they all play
into it?" What do you mean they all play into it? What does playing
into it even mean? Connor doesn't need to know. Connor wants
to believe, right? Connor is in the cult. He doesn't want to
actually figure this out. It's just entirely performative on
his part. He's just saying he will just listen. He will go, "Oh,
yeah. Yeah. Tell me tell me exactly what I what what to say,
what to think." There's no curiosity there. There's nothing.
He needs to have heard the counter talking point. If he hasn't
heard me or Quimman program him because he needs some father
figure in his life, he hasn't heard the actual counter talking
point. He has no
idea how to even engage in intellectual curiosity when Destiny
speaks to him. >> Ever earlier like murdering people, but
I would never do that. Yeah, never murder people. Um, not yet.
But the like the it's the there's like a game that works when
you're being you ever watch Mine Black 3? >> Uh no, but
we've talked about it. >> There's a game that works where
you can be kind of cutesy like Justicle and Queman are very good
at being like Twinky cutesy where they're like, "Oh, show me
in my community where somebody posted the docs or whatever."
And that works for like normies, but I'm not like I'm not going
to sit here and play that game. So if I have information about
you, if I can get your accounts banned, reported docs, whatever,
I'll do that all day 100%. There's a reason, by the way, why
just had to clean his Discord chat and why so many of their accounts
keep getting banned, by the way. But
>> because he's mass reporting my Discord. Yeah, we know
you're forgetting the Discord. Obviously, we knew that already.
That's Everybody knew that.
>> As an example, though, um somebody else, not you, >> by
the way, just fully admitting that he's bringing in the Discord,
right? which whatever I guess
>> um showed me uh evidence that uh a known Kiwi farmer
uh personality >> was in spicy chat known to be in spicy
chat. One of the profiles got banned and they had an alt with
the same PFP but a different name and there were like DMs or
logs or whatever where basically they were like oh yeah that's
me lol. And then they kept operating within spicy chat under
the same name. >> Wait, have you told me this? Uh, no.
Somebody else did. >> Do I know this person? >> Um,
yeah. >> By the way, that standard for Desty's behavior,
I'm sure that couldn't possibly be applied to like just so we
know. Okay. I don't advocate for this. I don't want I don't think
there's any reason, by the way, with regards to the Kylo stuff.
I don't think there's any reason that she should be taken off
of YouTube. Her contents, as far as I can tell, totally fine
for YouTube. I have no reason why. No understanding of why it
happened, right? But I am just telling you that like what he
just said, oh yeah, I don't care. I'm not going to play this
game. I know you're guilty of this. Now he's just totally justified
people going after his friends in this exact way, right? Which
is so stupid, but he wants that. He wants all those people negatively.
The only way he can keep friends is if they're scared of a bigger
boogeyman and they think Desi's going to protect them, right?
That's the only thing that keeps people close to him right now.
And then there's Connor who's like Lenny on the farm. Okay. Desi's
like, "Yeah, I'll tell you about I'll tell you about the farm
again. We're going to have one day Connor." And Connor's like,
"Tell me about the bunnies, David." You know, but other than
Connor, everybody else, they just think they're being protected
from like a bigger boogeyman. So, he wants he wants these people
scared. He wants other people to go hard on them, right? He needs
to paint the boogeyman. I don't care to be that boogeyman. I
don't want I don't want Erdite banned, right? For from no for
no reason other than Okay. Okay. There are other reasons, but
the the first reason I would give you is just that it's really
good money
to watch her and watch her like humiliate herself. That's incredible
money. Yeah, she got terminated from YouTube. They're going to
bring it up later in this as well, but I don't I don't think
she deserves that. I don't think she should be banned. Uh I like
totally disagree with it. But Desi's out here fully advocating
for like trying to deplatform people who have criticisms for
him. >> So I can show it to you later. >> Oh jeez.
I know there are a lot of pe I know there I there's at least
two people who have a heavy presence on Kiwi Farms and Inress
Fields community and I know they know they'll deny it if I say
it but yeah but so yeah the'll
deny. So just tell me all he has to do is say it unless he's
just going to like cuz when he says presence he has to mean posting
right he can't mean reading.
There's no way he could just mean reading because obviously he
reads Kiwi Farms all the time. Everybody around him reads Kiwi
Farms all the time,
right?
I don't think he could possibly just mean reading. I think it
has to mean interacting and like like actually participating
in some >> Absolutely. And everybody knows like this is
like a thing again where like um >> Well, and to be clear,
my evidence is 2 years old. >> Sure. But I'm saying like
this is a thing where like you can kind of like be cutesy if
you're talking to other people, but like everybody knows. It's
like open cigarettes. Yeah. Well, and then so here here's the
line because I'm trying to put this together and bear in mind
like the what is it like don't touch the poo is the >> that
used to be the thing for keepers. My thread is very special.
They are they take an active part in trying to be involved in
my life. Yeah. >> Yeah. So the old >> they don't
and Destiny was totally fine with the Keville's thread existing
and defended the Keville's thread existing when they're doxing
everyone around Keels. This guy is just transparently like zero
principles, right? Oh, it's happening to me now. It's bad. That's
all it is. old rule is, you know, don't touch the poo, don't
harass people, don't dox them, don't swat them, etc., etc. That
was the old rule. >> Um, so for me, I'm still trying to
play. >> No, there was never a rule against Kiwi Farms
has always been a doxing community. They've always been a place
where you can post docs. Docs is not the same. Having docs there
is not the same as uh like actually interacting.
Yes, that's never been a rule. >> Like, don't touch the
poo because I don't want to know. I don't want to know who these
people are. And I barely want >> By the way, Destiny is
completely making up that his thread is special. His thread is
not special. Other threads are the exact same as his. The Keell's
thread is almost certainly at its height far worse than Destiny's
thread. Like far more like cutting, far more, you know, hateful
of them. Like I I don't think Destiny's thread really stands
up to the Keville's thread in any way. Keville's thread was like
printing off like a 100 pages an hour. That [__]
was insane. All right.
>> Know me. M um but the the point though is so so we have
let's say that we have kiwi farms and the way >> oh that
is true wired rope that is actually true his is special because
he does directly interact with it that's >> talk about
it is that it's a uh it's a place where they effectively a log
somebody's information but then it does get weird where for instance
revenge is posted maintained until it's asked to be talked down
or brought down um addresses are posted they're left up until
they're
No, they're just left up. >> Okay. Phone numbers are posted.
Left up. >> There's a popular >> That [__]
was That's how Kiwi Farms has always been. Unless I'm mistaken.
Is this not how Kiwi Farms has always been? >> Leftist
account, I think, that posted some audio of me sucking some dude
off yesterday on his Twitter account. Nobody gives a Yeah, it's
all memes. Yeah. >> So, sorry, I I blinked just to >> Yeah,
it's all good times. Yeah. >> Um, so so anyway, so they
leave that stuff up and then the the thing is like they're like,
"Oh, well, we don't docks. We don't harass." But realistically,
if you wanted to harass somebody, if you wanted to swat somebody,
that's where you would find it. >> 100%. Yeah. >> So
then, but that's not illegal to have that information up,
>> Then you have Discords, which probably do have stricter
I don't know what the terms of service are, but they probably
have do have stricter. >> Yeah. You can't I think you'll
get banned for that. Yeah. >> Okay. So, they have they
have stricter things. And so, what'll happen is, at least as
far as I understand, is the Discords are places where people
like chat [__] talk about internet
>> Yeah. We can point out that obviously it's a non-conensually
recorded audio in that case as well. Yes, it obviously is. He's
talking about the He's almost certainly talking about the non-consentually
recorded Grinder audio. He was talking about anime. That was
actually one of the funny things is one of the times that I was
checking in on a Discord that was talking about me and talking
about you. Um, they got distracted by anime and they talked about
anime for like 24 hours and then they went back to talking. Um,
but anyways, uh, the point is that like there's no illicit thing
within this frame. There's no >> He means us, by the way.
Okay. Connor just left recently. I think >> no evidence
of harassment or stalking or swatting within this frame, but
it's kind of I don't know like um
I want to say inculcating,
but I think there's a better word. Incubating >> kind of.
Yeah, it'll be a thing where like if you were to post something
on KF, it'll be they'll talk about it almost immediately in the
Yes. Correct. Yes. And so they all know where they're going and
then they're talking inside Discords and like group chats about
it. Yeah. 100%. >> So for you there's like the the whatever
thin wall between these these communities might as well not exist.
>> Yeah. It's not there. Yeah. It's actually funny because
people accuse me of doing it, but for me it was the exact opposite.
And I would be happy people did what I did. People say, "Oh,
um, some people try to run with this cute thing." I only know
about Kiw cuz Destiny all Destiny told us to go there to harass
Anna. Have you ever heard this claim before? >> Of course.
>> Yeah. Just and the other uh
I didn't say that about me. That's literally the Blav origin
story. He's just talking about the Blav origin story that Blav
was a DGER, right? And that this guy only found out about Kiwi
Farms because Destiny pointed people to Anavor's Kiwi Farms.
I'll bring this up where they're saying that like I drove people
to Kiwi Farms. My announcement and you go find the clip. You
should ask them for it. They never He's my announcement was I
didn't want any of these people around me. Actually, I would
be totally fine if JTO sent everybody to Kiwi Farms who wanted
to like talk about me. If you just sent them to a smaller platform,
if you just sent them to a platform with less engagement, I would
be Yeah, I know you would, but it's not the same group of people
and you're just trying to blend them together. Play it. But like
what I told people because there was a lot of stuff that was
being posted in Kiwi Farms and then my chat was viewing it a
lot and then they would start talking about it in my chat. And
what I said to my chat was, "Hey, if you want to talk about like
weird related to [__] go to KF and talk about it.
Don't do it in my community. I don't want to see that here ever.
Period." And people just How long did he hold on to that for?
Cuz when I joined DG, I remember with Taber, okay, watching some
anor meltdown streams and it was way after that. It wasn't after
It was It was way after this had gotten like outlawed. I know
for a fact it was. So, how much did you actually enforce that?
And how much did you keep that going? Or did you just send a
bunch of people to kiwi farms, run that rule for like two weeks,
two months tops, and then just get rid of that rule cuz you're
a [__] What is this total you're coming up with?
And then we'll morph that into like, oh, look, he was sending
people to her. But I wasn't. I wanted it out of my community.
And the fact that it was and I know cuz I'm not an idiot and
I'm honest about how the communities work. He's lying transparently
about how these communities work that I watched via Anavar's
stream like a dozen times when I first joined his community.
I don't know what the [__] he's talking about right
now. If it's on Kiwi Farms and then it starts getting spoken
about in my chat immediately, there's always going to be an interplay
there because they know like if I type in my chat, I know that
Kiwi Farms is watching and that happens back and forth. Yeah.
>> The the rebuttal is that you're playing 5D chess though
with that. >> That's I don't have the only time I'm playing
5D chess or I'm like an enigmatic complicated figure or there
it's just cuz people just don't believe
what I'm saying at face value. And it's like I think >> so
Anavoir was like not talked about in your chat after that. not
brought up on your stream, not brought up in your chat is what
you're saying. It's pretty obvious like why would I like what
would even be the 5D chess >> the 5D chess thing >> like
I'll tell you like I'm telling you flat like there are people
I will ducks if I have the opportunity to do is getting posted
if I get it my hands on 100% but I'm not like I don't have to
sit here and like oh well
uh
that by the way that is also a call to action right there that
he's openly doing while sitting next to Connor Hold on hold on
hold on wait
wait let's get Let's get a better version of this clip going.
Okay. Uh oh, chat's kind of in the way. We don't want chat here
right now. We don't want chat here right now. Let's uh let's
make sure that we got the uh the Valor Media Network approved
doxing. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. I Connor approve this message.
>> The 5D chess. >> The 5D chess thing 100%. I'm
telling you flat like there are people I will ducks if I have
the opportunity to. Do is getting posted if I get it my hands
on it 100%. But I'm not like I don't have to sit here and like
I'm not I don't need to 5D. Let's
go. Hold up. >> But for Anna, like I legit
>> amazing amazing
stuff. And this guy accuses me of like any of these things, bro.
What are we What are we doing here? Wick will say this isn't
a threat somehow.
Dude, I think I think Wick's like totally that one with his community.
That'll be a tough one. Okay, there we go. There we go. There
we go. There we go. Oh, what the [__] Get out of
here. Get out of here, little Connor. Oh, I need to pull chat
back, though. Why is my chat not coming back? Hello. There it
is. There we go. I think I need to make that chat smaller anyway.
It's like cutting Connor off. Chat's got to be tiny. Tiny chat.
>> Die. What is Doobie's sin? >> The being in the
in cahoots all these weirdo a loggers that are obsessively >> Okay,
this has to be Hold on. This has to be where Connor breaks up
that like Doobie's just been introduced, right?
He's just been introduced to this and he's already Destiny's
like I will dox this right now.
No. By the way, Connor, this is the really important part where
you need to ask for evidence because it Destiny has tried to
collect [__] on me or Queen or whoever for months
now, right? There might be something he could like weave together
to say like, "Oh, here's like why just in terms of we talk about
this guy a lot, right?" And and and it would look good to like
a cultist type person maybe, but it's all built post Hawk. It's
all built after he started trying to do it. So, I'd say on the
Doobie front, I don't think Destiny has any info on Dubbie. I
don't think he has any idea what Doobie was saying. He thought
Dubbie was posting in spicy chat. Okay, Dwey been banned from
spicy chat for like a year and a half, two years. Okay? Like,
he has no information here. He has no proof of this. And he's
going to say, "Yeah, get me Dubbies docs. I'll post it as soon
as I can." Because none of it is built on him actually understanding
or knowing anything. It's just built on his Fifi. Okay? And his
Fifi are pretty hurt right now. His Fifi are not Fifiing so good.
>> Talking about me, talking about me to every other person
and doing this weird pressure game in the background for every
single person when he was in Wix chat because he got blown the
out by Baby Peach debate. Um where they're playing all these
weirdo pressure games. It's just weird. Anybody that's part of
like those communities in my mind, it's all these weirdo pressure
games of like, "Hey Wick, you said doxers are banned. Destiny
is openly doxing. Now he's openly threatening a community member
of with doxing, right? He says he will dox this guy as soon as
he can. Right. That's that's not a weirdo pressure game. That's
saying, "Hey, we argue in a community where it's like we do moral
arguments with each other." Right? We do this all the time. You
said you have a moral aversion to doxing. You have cut off people
for things that are like doc.
Are you going to follow through on this principle with destiny?
That's not weirdo. And he doesn't he doesn't even have evidence
of what the weirdo [__]
>> Jesus. It's It's so weird that the court keeps protecting
these people's identities. It's so weird, guys. Isn't it It's
so weird and unhinged. The judges are so unhinged for entertaining
this protective order. The judges are so unhinged for letting
all these motions come through. >> The I got to got to
back it up a little bit talking about me to every other person
and doing this weird pressure game in the background for every
single person when he was in Wix chat pain cuz he got blown the
out by Baby Peach debate. Um where they're playing all these
weirdo pressure games. It's just weird. Anybody that's part of
like those communities in my mind is all to me. >> Jesus
the Okay, so the
pressure games do scene their Okay. Well, and then I was going to
bring this up to you as well. >> So, and >> evidence.
No,
Conor. Connor, shouldn't you ask for what pressure games means?
What creepy weirdo behavior means? Uh what what proof Destiny
has of these things? Right? Shouldn't you be asking any of these
questions? Literally all Connor is doing is he's getting enough
information so he can go, "This is what Destiny said." And it'll
be like, "Connor, do you think that's a valid excuse?" No, that's
what Destiny said. This is He just wants to have his new talking
points programmed in so that he can uh so that he can go, "Well,
that's not my position. It's just Destiny's, >> I think
I brought it up to you earlier today. So, I on our >> Oh,
you know what? We might need another uh we need another one of
these stamps, guys. Okay. We need another stamp. We don't just
need the Valor Media Network approval, stamp of approval from
Connor. Okay, we might need an UN America Z Cohen Sanchez. Could
we get an UN America National Ground Game seal of approval on
these clips where Desi's like threatening to dox random politics
streamers, politics panelists? I don't even know if Doobie streams
on his own. >> Ironically, like I said, I'm not a religious
literalist, but I do believe in like religious precepts. And
one of the religious precepts effectively is like you know turning
the other cheek or the mercy sin forgiveness pipeline where it's
effectively like guilt
uh it's like sin guilt
um asking for mercy atonement forgiveness and that cycle for
the unfamiliar is like at least within Christianity if you commit
a sin and you feel guilty uh they correlate then you kind of
seek mercy uh from the people that you wronged you try to atone
which means try to create some justice in the world. Um, and
then even if those people can't forgive you, ultimately God is
supposed to forgive you if you're serious with your atonement.
>> So, Conor's been trying to shoehorn them into this conversation.
Desessie's like he is like the the toddler with the, you know,
it's the broccoli. Okay. Connor is like the the adult trying
to feed Destiny his broccoli and Desty's like, "No, no, I don't
want it. I don't want to eat it. I don't want to eat it." And
it's the moral the Christian the Christian moral ethics thing
where it's like guys it's like sin what is it acknowledgement
mercy atonement
forgiveness or something I think I think that's it whatever it
was from a stupid >> along with turning the other cheek
is supposed to make a more >> this is fantastic you're
not Lauren southern Connor he's not going to pretend to be religious
for you
>> may well maybe there's two huge assumptions though one
>> is that there's some afterlife where I get to read the
rewards of that and two is that I can infinitely tank whatever
cuz I have God on my side. So, as an atheist, neither of those
things are very compelling to me. I don't know if the arc of
history inevitably bends towards some positive direction. So,
I don't know if there's some moral goodness in allowing other
people to infinitely slander you with no >> no what theible
>> may well there's two huge >> I started typing
a a [__] Discord message though. One >> is
that there's some afterlife where I get to reap the rewards of
that and two is that I can infinitely tank whatever cuz I've
got on my side. So, as an atheist, neither of those things are
very compelling to me. I don't know if the arc of history inevitably
bends towards some positive direction. So, I don't know if there's
some moral goodness in allowing other people to infinitely slander
you with no response. >> What about reciprocity?
>> I with no response. You don't have to respond. You could
actually, by the way, I've never said this would be bad. Destiny
could actually just look at the content that I've done, the allegations,
and how I've covered his and he could just respond to it. I have
no problem with that. That would be totally morally justified.
That would be good, right? But he can't respond to it. If he
could respond to it, that would be his first tactic. That's what's
missing here is Destiny, why don't you just respond to what they're
saying? Why don't you just show how they're lying about you?
No, he's never attempted this. He's never once attempted this,
right? The closest he's ever come is watching Queen's response
that he basically didn't pay attention to. The Queenman's response
to the Willy Mac thing, right? That's the closest he ever come.
Other than that, he's never once tried to response or sorry,
respond to the content of the criticism. And that comes way before
trying to dox people. By the way, if he had a real response to
basically anything I've been saying since this all kicked off
in January,
he would have done so and he wouldn't have lost anywhere near
as much of his audience. The fact that he hasn't ever tried to
respond tangibly to the things I say is is perfect proof that
he has no response. I fully believe Mr. president earlier. I
think when we were upstairs, you mentioned something about the
doxing thing and you like 2 years ago you said that this was
like a line and it was horrible. I agree 100%. I think it's horrible.
I don't think anybody should be doing it. I'm not going to stop
though. They're not going to stop because I like I hope that
they do. Uh his response would be that he does not want to give
you any more public attention.
That's fine. Then don't give me public attention and don't start
trying to like dox me or other people around me. Easy. Super
easy. Just ignore it. But if your first step to action isn't
to respond, it's just to try to dox people, then you're obviously
in the wrong. You're just obviously in the wrong to everybody
with any sense. You feel uncomfortable. I hope that they don't
enjoy it. I hope that it really does worry some of them because
I've had to live with that for years. Like I said, I got swatted
when my son was here, right? I'm outside with multiple AR-15s
pointed at me having to explain that my son is inside my apartment
with a whole bunch of guns, but he doesn't know how to use them
and he's too scared to come out. This is a very I'm don't know if
that footage can be foyed. These are very stressful situations.
So when somebody tells me like, "Well, isn't doxing them too
far?" I think >> like we've just actually completed the
uh Yeah, by the way, being swatted would be awful, right? Why
say that? Um he wants people to realize he's a victim. Being
swatted would be awful. Was he swatted before or after? Like
I thought I was still I thought I was still friends with him
when he got swatted when Nathan was there. Isn't that the This
Destiny guy is cooked.
I thought I thought we were still I thought that was in like
uh December or something. Maybe I'm wrong. Oh, it was before.
Okay, so it was before. So the things he's blaming on me or anyone
around me. Oh my god.
It was during the Trump. Oh, so this is just total horseshit.
He's like, "Oh, I want these people to be scared cuz I live with
this." But he's he's also blaming us for the situation he was
in before any of us were like doing this kind of content, like
talking about his >> I think it is too far, but I'm I've
been way over that line so at this point. Yeah, if I saw them
taking a stronger stance against it where I was like, "Okay,
like I can see like people have Oh, so it's just a blatant lie.
This is just blatant manipulation. He's making himself a victim
for something that happened way before.
This is the not so aerodyite playbook." Amazing. Or this Nathan
swatting happened after we just don't know about it. I don't
know. But I'm I'm pretty sure I remembered it happening before
cuz I thought Nathan talked about it. I thought I covered that
Nathan talked about it. Pressured or said things in the background
like, "Oh, like do you think we should do like like these guys
or whatever?" I'm like, "No, they're not even part of this [__]
Like, I don't care about like this stuff um or whatever." But
when it comes to like the weird spicy chat, u justical queman,
uh Kiwi Farms, that pipeline, and then like the and then how
that connects up to like Bad Empan and Assan, these people are
these are terrorists.
No, the connection again. Conor Connor said it and Dest Well,
if you want to say that, you could say that. Yeah, the connection
is we think you're disgusting. They're
uh who do I if I wanted to be a terrorist group, who would I
want to be? I don't really want to be Hezbollah. Although Nisrala
was kind of funny sometimes when he wasn't just a raging anti-semite.
Um I don't know. These people are unh.
I'd say FLQ if uh if Trudeau hadn't totally mogged them. Okay.
Trudeau hadn't totally mogged them. I'd say FLQ. >> Deranged.
Like I have no consideration. They're crazy. >> The Okay.
So, you said something that was honestly I was re-watching
uh the Keles drama because it's some of Chudlo Logic's best work.
>> And in the Keles drama, uh she talked about how Ontario,
I think it was
>> um somebody else. >> Anyways, police showed up
to her house. Uh they had they had rifles and pistols and stuff.
They were outside of the door. They asked her to come out, but
they did like the call out order where they came out. And what
you described to me was kind of parallel where you were saying
like you had a swatting incident where several armed law enforcement
officers not with pistols but with rifles actually showed up
to your front >> Yeah. And it's weird too. I think I was
probably more stressed than Nathan cuz I don't like obviously
if you spent any time at the range which you have. I'm going
to be pointing a gun at you is very weird. That's a very good
>> Yeah. Um and then also when you have the multiple cops
shouting I see that the Ben is it Ben Shaver? >> There's
one of those. Yeah, for sure. I think I think it's Daniel, but
>> Oh, Daniel Shaver. Yeah. And I'm like, I'm going to
die in the most way. So, this is all totally like fine. You can
be scared of getting swatted. Swatting is scary. And this is,
by the way, he's describing a real swatting. This is like actual
swatting. When they show up with rifles and they are being told
there's a dangerous situation, they have to proceed fast or somebody's
going to get hurt. And they don't have like like there's a time
pressure, there's a danger pressure, right? That's actual swatting.
But then the question becomes, did this happen before or after
the people who you're mad about a logging you started like a
logging you in some way? Which happened first? Possible cuz these
are all shouting different things at me. Yeah, >> you're
going to do uh like >> Simon says execution in the hallway.
>> [__] the Vos clip. I don't think that's
horrible. Um sorry. The only reason why I'm laughing is because
I uh yeah, I've I've been >> I just want to say cuz when
he did get swatted while his son was there, he was smart enough
not to bring attention to it. We only knew because
>> his son brought about brought it up in his Discord.
It's very possible something could have happened again and he's
smart enough not to mention it, right? And so he's going to try
to mention it but through like the past
>> Oh, maybe. >> Who knows? I >> I would just
want I would just want clarification cuz I I would hope since
Arerodite has done this I hope he's not doing the same thing
where he's saying oh this is because the argument is that because
of me and Quimman like the ramped up and we're like giving targets
to people we're coordinating with right but it's like all of
this happened before we got involved at all before we were doing
negative content about it while Queen was kind of doing negative
content about it. No, I agree. So, because it happened before
you guys were involved, this is attention that he's brought on
himself a couple of times. If it's happened recently, don't be
like, "Please make it clear. Tell me if it happened again." Like,
I feel like you should never do that to somebody. But you can
just use the fact that it's happened previously to be like, "This
is you, buddy. This is your >> sure on the internet." >> I'm
just generally saying that I think like you don't have to give
me a recent time or anything. You just say if it was before or
after.
>> But but also Yeah, you're right that it was already
a thing that was happening.
>> Yep. 100%. I I need to come up with a thing to make
it swap faster. Get her a mic. I have another mic. I just have
to set it up at some point. I'd have to go listen also to how
well it comes through. What?
>> Okay, we're back. We're back. >> Situation where
I had a uh firearm
uh there was a firearm in an irresponsible party's hand and they
were not friendly to me. And so yeah, that's terrifying because
you basically know >> within a second or two uh you can
get get your life snatched out of your body. So it's mad uncomfortable
>> on camera too.
>> The worst part is like the dying sucks. So the worst
part is knowing that these losers are going to be like celebrating
and clapping about their streams. >> They would they would
have >> if I get killed by the cops before gets k by cherry.
That would just be an epic on my part. So >> all right
the we used to all be friends. >> I also agree that would
be shad. Oh, wait. No, that would be awesome. Okay, that's crazy.
>> What's up? >> I literally come in here to say
something peaceful and then I got to hear that [__]
all the time. I am going to kill you, but it's not because he
told me to. >> Awesome. Love you, too. Anyway, we
okay.
So, their contention is that this is a one-way street. They're
not participating in these behaviors. You're
>> of course, >> what you think is do you think that's
[__] or do you think I'm crazy? >> I have no
idea. And and I'm not saying that because I'm I'm not saying
that to be cute or play both sides or whatever. The reason why
I'm saying that is because I am very stupid in one regard. When
people say things to me, I believe that what they're saying is
what they're thinking and it correlates with their perception
of reality. >> Okay, hold on. This is dangerously close
to introspection and growth is we're right there. Do not get
mad. do not get mad right now. >> And I've had that problem
the entire time. And so when people lie to me, I'm oftentimes
the only way that I find out that somebody is lying is if like
it's 100% proven the opposite of true. And I the funny thing
is is I I don't know about Queen can't speak for him, right?
I've had to operate this way the whole time. When I say right,
when I say and I'm like arguing about anything to do with Desi,
I have to have like dead set proof on these things like every
time cuz people will hold me like to the highest bar. And then
Desi says the most brain damaged.
He just totally openly lies and nobody checks him. It's so annoying.
Okay. Oh sh
Oh sh Oh, >> in my last video I
the Destiny situation is unhinged.
He can't even He can't even escape the destinyism in the title.
Crazy.
Willie Max show 12 seconds ago. Well, we'll have to finish the
Connor thing. God, I'm like I wish these people would shut the
up. Okay, I wish they would all shut the [__] up
so I could do other content cuz I'm not interested in them. But
sometimes, listen, this is a good convo. This is fun to react
to. Okay. >> I would say that uh I have talked to Queenman
or whatever. I sent him some uh information that I felt was relevant
to the situation and he seemed to be like I don't know uh entertaining
the ideas, I
>> What do you mean by entertaining the ideas? He's part
of it. He's actively part of it. What do you mean by entertaining
ideas? >> Well, right. But that's the um uh effectively
entertaining the ideas that there might be evidence between the
correlates uh between Kiwi Farms harassers and the Discords.
>> So he was saying like, "Okay, yeah, this is a possibility.
However, I need to do research for XYZ ABC." >> Okay. So
he's just lying. He's just saying she shouldn't play. You're
saying he's [__] lying until he knows 100% what's
going on. Yeah. He's a huge part of it. But >> that's okay.
All right. >> Well, that's I'm sure I'm sure I'll get another
DM where he's like, "No, I'm not lying. Destiny is the one that's
lying. He's a [__] musician. He should kill
>> right? All right. So, >> here's like um this is
like an example. Uh if you really want later, I could find I
don't really like to show it on stream. Um so, this was said
I think about a day after like a third fan of mine had been um
they're just doxing random fans of mine on >> No. Didn't
they get um I'm not saying it's related, but Tech got doxed like
two weeks after. >> No, that's not related. I don't know
about that. Don't know about that. Don't care about that. Don't
know about that. Don't care about that. Don't know about that.
Don't care about that. Okay. >> But well, actually maybe
but I didn't see if it was >> chronologically. I found
it. >> So they're literally talking like random people.
Uh >> who's I what does random mean? When Destiny says
random, it's almost never random. I want to know what what he
means by random here. >> On on keeps who are my fans, right?
>> This is um I don't know if this is Coin or Dior. I'm
mixing these guys up a lot now. But this is um No, no, wait.
Just stay over there. You just listen. Okay. Okay. This is just
to go watching one of these fat guys watch my stream and then
I think he sees somebody on Twitter. Just listen to the Hold
on. >> Oh, they put it all in the thing. It's like the
guy's a rage cow. He's lashing out. He's doing any damage he
possibly >> This guy's talking to me. >> Incorrect.
That's >> go down with that ship. Be my guest. All right.
Because you Oh, I used to >> Notice how he said that. If
you want to go down with that [__] be my guest. That's
not true, though. You don't have the ability to go down that
ship because they will hunt you and chase you and try to divide
you and whatever, right? They don't give you the opportunity
to do that. But yeah, go ahead. Like, bro, I don't give a [__]
who respects me on this at all whatsoever. To me, you're just
another name in the chat. Nobody >> He says he doesn't
give a The only reason, by the way, why Willie Mack made that
phone call and recorded it and then published a video about it,
giving me time to Just kidding. But the only reason he did that,
by the way, was because Dioro I'm I'm just saying it's a really
stupid video like that. If you really do believe this, it's really
But um the only reason Will is because Dioro pressured him to
do that. Just you know. Um and there's Dioro's on Dior's on >> Oh,
I'm not muted. I'm not muted. I just wanted to let that uh image
speak for itself there. >> Saying that that he's the one
who like pushed him really hard to do that. But okay, hold on.
Listen to the >> Oh, god damn it. So many people only watch.
I When that happened, I pulled up the tweet of Willie saying
everything Destiny is saying here is true. The part where it's
like, okay, why would you make that video and publish it? You
can make the video. In fact, I encourage you to make the video
and just show that you did it. Uh just in case people, you know,
people call you out and say, "Oh, you didn't do anything." Right?
You could keep proof of that. You could let people know about
that, but probably like letting it putting it out immediately,
publishing it immediately is a little silly. >> My publish
is because Doro pressured him to do that just, you know. Um,
and there's Dor is on Dior's on stream saying that that he's
the one who like pushed him really hard to do that. But, okay,
hold on. Listen to the >> Are you going to go past skip
past the tablet he keeps with clips of you at the
>> Uh, no. He's You understand how much he watches the
stream, right? Like he is always watching the stream. He is always
here. Always. I'm not shocked that he's got a Dude, if only this
guy could get past me thinking he's like a totally degenerate,
harmful piece of [__] who like cannot is not capable
of accepting uh or respecting other people's consent. If if I
could get past that, okay, if I could just stop hating this guy,
maybe he could get stop maybe he could uh channel his abilities
for good. Maybe he could be like my strongest clipper,
right? He's like right there. He could be my strongest clipper
if we just could tweak this relationship a little bit. >> How
is anybody saying I don't respect you? He's just being like,
Destiny's a liar. I don't want to defend this guy at all. This
guy sucks. Somebody apparently is saying, "Nick, I don't respect
you to
>> So, he's talking about somebody in chat. This is a chatter
that said this. And then this was saying, >> "Find that
person. >> Find that person. >> Person is not safe
to be around children or women." Okay? >> Find that person.
Mark them for the good of society. Okay? They need they need
to be tracked right at the beginning. >> So, he's saying
this. I do mean the alias. Like, we need to know the alias. I
don't mean doxing them,
I'm like I'm literally just joking. But hey, it is what it is.
Jesus Christ. What's this? Oh, don't pull that up on stream.
Disavow that. Oh, somebody banned him already. Okay. Thank you.
Appreciate the ban. Jesus. Got you. You're cooked. I I do like
basically laughing at like to me the funny thing that happens
recently is how like insane some of the chatters are like how
it's very obvious when it's like one person comes in they're
like didn't he like not know her age right the whole time but
you know
if that guy if that guy got doxed I would feel bad about that
okay I feel bad for singling him out yeah maybe I'll I'll reflect
on that you know calling people out while it is funny. While
it is a lot of fun, I might have to think about how to how to
censor that out for people. Okay, that's a meme. And if you would
push him, they go like, "Oh, does something." But they're like
one of the guys that got doed on Kiwi Farms. This was the basically
exactly what they were saying. This guy's not safe to women or
children and he works as this job. So, we're going to email his
employer. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. He's not talking about
Odish right now, is he? No, maybe he's not. I don't know what
he's talking about. I literally don't know what he's talking
about and we're going to try to like get him fired from his This
is the guy who emailed me said to call the cops. So Jessica reads
his thread. >> Wait, who is this? He's lying. I don't know
if he's not talking about Odishara. I don't know who he's talking
about, right? Because the only person I think he could be talking
about here is Odashara. And that's not even remotely the story
with Odashara.
I have no idea what this is. >> That's cuz they all read
him and post about him. So he knows what he's doing. But it's
always like stuff like that. There's like dozens of examples
of like >> dozens of examples. Show two more. He's talking
about Odashar and he's lying about the framing. Yeah, Odashar
is a total and obviously lied about what happened with regards
to that entire situation. And I'm I'm positive he lied about
like any letter getting sent to him. If you don't know the story
about Odashar, this is a Destiny fan who said that he was doxed
and somebody dropped a letter off at his house making fun of
him. Now, the things that they said to make fun of him in that
letter happened happened to overlap one to one with what he was
really upset people in voice chat were saying about him that
he was like a
or something which I'm sorry is just funny you okay he was very
upset about that and so he said because nobody would ban those
people for laughing at him he started spamming fs slurs in VC
and got banned from the server right he got timed out then he
basically while he was timed out he said I got a letter to my
house and they were saying the same thing. So you have to stop
them from doing this and it's like okay
can you show me the letter? No, he threw it out as soon as he
got it. Okay, so he threw out the letter as soon as he got it.
I said that was pretty crazy. Eventually he just kept pushing.
He's like I'm not even sure. I'm like 98% sure it wasn't even
somebody from your server. And I'm like okay I think you are
just lying. I actually just think you're lying. I think you're
making this up entirely. That's that's the story I think he is
currently trying to recount.
>> Yeah. Always. It's how they work. Yeah. But this is
like the goal. That's how they do it. Yeah. So now if you're
in the future, you talk about chilling effect. O, do I really
want to say anything bad about these guys? Like Jesus. Like what
if he calls me out and then I'm the next person that gets doxed
on Kiwi Farms and they post my Yeah. Would they did this happen?
Hold on. He said this happened. Now I need like any evidence
of this cuz I don't recall this happening, right? I don't know
who this could possibly I I would need to see any evidence of
this. I hope Connor sees evidence of it, right? I hope Connor
takes this transcript and asks for exact receipts of the things
Destiny just said happened to show that Destiny wouldn't just
go on this stream and lie to both Connor and his audience about
what happened. Right. He's a serial docer himself. What the [__]
Uh yeah, he is. I'm just saying that I really hope the chilling
effect is tendency. Dude, I just want to uh I would just like
to see Connor ask for this evidence of like the things he said
here and just make sure it matches up to what actually happened.
>> the I have a totally unproductive, stupid idea in my
brain, but at the same time, it's like it seemed like
a year ago, two years ago, uh if we had beef, and this is something
that I respected you for, uh effectively like having open coms
even with like really small
>> So if somebody had beef, they could basically come say
it to your face. Now though, it seems like the game is >> I'm
totally down for any of these people to come talk to me. I literally
have s I don't want to talk to Destiny cuz he's gross. Like I
He's just gross. Okay, not really interested in that. But essentially
everybody else I'm totally down to talk to >> this doc
war
and
um I don't know like there there's no treaty here. >> Well,
because um there's no diplomacy there. There's no like like what
what how could we get and >> we can't we can't
come into a room and say hey Stephen I think you're the biggest
piece of [__] on the [__] and I hope
you die one day and then boom it's squashed >> no because
that's not the goal um I don't remember we were talking about
the beginning of this at the beginning of this conversation unironically
yes that is the goal the goal is to one of those two things either
for me to kill myself somebody around me to kill themselves or
to destroy my career right the perfect example of this >> what
happens if they don't get it >> then they just then they'll
try to do it to the people around me look at how they they spam
a picto channel why do you think it got terminated today. >> Well,
and that that's another thing, too, is like >> there's
no evidence anywhere that we spam reported Kyla. We don't want
Kyla gone. We literally pay our bills monthly based on Kyla existing.
I literally have multiple multiple Okay, multiple Kyla soundboards
on my
I don't want Kyla banned from the internet. I don't want her
gone. I I don't we don't want her gone. Been waiting on her response.
Well, she did get terminated and I can show you guys exactly
like the evidence of that and stuff, but I don't want her banned.
Uh, I had I'll show this tweet right now. Um, we got accused
of this like immediately and I'll show you the predicate upon
which we're being accused of doing this. Okay, which is uh I
say we cuz it seems like Aiden's getting accused of it, which
makes no sense,
but like dude, this is uh last night.
>> Uh, Marty Epstein, thank you for the five gifted. Let's
go. Thank you very much. Appreciate it, buddy. All right, this
thinking monk guy comes in. Big surprise atx. So, there's this
log from apparently um somebody in food shops chat says, "I'm
telling you, it's Aiden's community. They have been working on
it for a while about not so Aerodite." Right.
So, this guy says exiled Aiden Jtock at Queenman at Nicholas
at Willymack at not food shops at the omniiberal
and they're like, "Oh, this is about Aerodite getting uh banned
or whatever, right?" as like this is this is the level of evidence
they need to make these allegations these kinds of allegations.
No, food shops didn't tell them that. That's just a random chatter
in food shops that said this. Okay, I just respond like dude,
why the [__] would have we want to report such a
consistent source of content.
It doesn't make any sense. Our this entire time, okay, we have
one weapon. It's the only weapon we're interested in using, okay?
It's our voices. That's the only weapon we use. We just talk
to people. We talk to people. We talk about people. We analyze
content. We speak about it. It's just a voice. That's the only
thing. That's the only blade. Okay? That's the only blade with
we engage in using. There is nothing else. It's not even a screenshot.
It's not. It's not. Dude, we just want the We just want to not
get lied about. Occasionally, we make some horrendous meme videos
or meme donations. Dung devil, there's no shot you actually fell
for the troll. Fell for the troll from the guy who pretends to
be an Indian woman all day. Kathy. Uh, yeah. This is like like
honestly this is by the way this is one of Destiny's top guys.
The thinking monk guy. It's one of Destiny's top guys. Like they've
gone beyond they've like jumped the shark. They literally are
worse than like the Qinon people. Like this is crazy that something
bad happens and they immediately
I feel bad cuz I'm not if only I was. Okay. Then we could just
say they instantly jump. Anything bad happens. They stub their
toe and they blame the me and queen in that case if I were right.
They just blame
but they just blame me. Bro, I don't do I'm not doing this. I
don't have time to worry about what Aerodite's doing. Yeah. So,
she got reported last night. Uh, so she says she got reported.
I I don't know that she has any indication she was like mass
reported. She says it right. Hey at team YouTube, my YouTube
account not so erodite seems to have been taken down. I believe
this is likely due to mass reporting. I've already made an appeal.
Anyone willing to support and get human eyes on it, I would appreciate
that. will update tomorrow. Totally understand where you're coming
from. Clarify there's no amount of reporting/ flagging that can
enforce our policies on content if we don't find any v violations
on it. We understand how important this is to you. Since you've
already submitted an appeal, we recommend waiting for an update
from our policy team. Appreciate your patience in the meantime.
Should you respond to this at all? Uh, somebody else asked something
else. Oh, there's something else that happened here. I think
she talked more about it cuz I think there's another post. Here
we go. Hey, at team YouTube, thanks for the reply. My 55K sub
channel ran three years with zero strikes. On August 26th to
27th, two old videos were removed. Then my whole channel was
terminated before I even had a chance to review them. Appeal
was autorejected. My appeal of my account removal was denied
within minutes of it being made. Can you please escalate escalate
for a manual review?
Um,
I'll be honest. This is the place I'm
Unlucky. Uh, maybe if she finds maybe if she figures something
out, she can let me know what happened. Okay. How she got out
of it. This is the place I'm in. I go to I go to like appeal
my and it's auto. It's algorithmically denied, right? Like insta
algorithmically denied. You previously received a warning for
your content. We're not we're not giving you a strike this time,
but we removed the content from YouTube.
None in my files. Unclear what this references. Uh you can see
an example around 7 seconds. We're not giving you a strike at
this time. Was August 27th, August 26th,
August 27th.
and then a termination.
August 31st, 1:20 a.m. August 31st, 2:58 a.m. We've reviewed
the appeal for the following.
Uh, confirmed it violates our hate speech policy. Pay attention
on these dates. It wasn't overnight. What? Well, there's a multiple
days here. I don't know what you mean by not overnight. Uh, let's
see here. My appeal
not accepted.
Totally hear concern. Mind following us so we can continue via
DM followed. the next steps bring to this channel following to
find out if YouTube does the right thing that my channel was
even older. Also had no strikes and was also removed for no reason.
It's like you've already appealed and received an email outlining
the final decision. We know it wasn't the outcome you're hoping
for, but there's nothing more we can do. This dude, the bots,
the bots are so crazy. It's just all AI. She had time to respond.
She did have time to respond. I just have no idea
what other content was there and I don't know how she would respond
necessarily. Right. This hate speech policy, hate speech policy.
more hate speech policy.
Turns out, okay, it's more than just the Democrats who don't
like people saying
How up would it be if it was those videos where she calls herself
a and she says she's a part of the cohort. Dude, that'd be crazy.
That would be insane,
Oh, that would be I don't think that happened. And honestly,
I hope she gets her channel back. It's It's really stressful
when you're like making a living this way and this like gets
taken away from you like instantly, right? with like not a lot
of warning in her case. No warning in my case, but yeah, nobody
reported her. Nobody reported her. Um, I don't celebrate her
getting taken down. I think some people in my community might
dislike her enough to celebrate it getting taken down. Uh, I
totally dis like I I totally disagree with that. I don't even
have to disavow it. I disagree with that, but like I don't know
if I'm supposed to moderate that. So, Kyla deals with like red
pill content and stuff that I'm sure that if the other person
talking
was getting reported could be a terms of service violation, but
I don't think Kyla's ever
done a terms of service violation >> Sure. You know, you
can find logs in all the big Discords, Justicles, um, and Spicy
Chat where people are celebrating that her channel got banned.
They're like, "Yes, we >> Oh, that would be really bad.
Could you imagine if I controlled a channel where people celebrated
Kyla Kyla's channel getting banned? >> Got him. >> We
got him. >> Um, I don't know if we got him. I check, but
yeah. >> Oh, we got them. Oh, wait. Hold on.
I don't think this is precisely what was said. I think somebody
sent me the log specifically. The response is let's go,
which is not a we got them. It's a let's go that happened in
my channel.
There was only one There was only one message celebrating and
it was you. You're an that does not mean anybody did this or
wanted this to happen, right? I don't think celebrating means
we did it or wanted it to happen, right? Or if it does, then
I got some bad news for Destiny. Okay, he's he's a real [__]
for this. Okay, this this thread is JTO was banned on YouTube.
Community guideline violation.
And who is here? here. Uh, who's here celebrating it? Of course.
Oh god, what happened? Can I Can I get the spot? Okay. Who is
here celebrating it? Of course. Haha. Casey Tron and Jtock back
toback. This is my finest day. I think this is a packwatch gift.
Okay. Porth thought alt learning from Tom. I see. I will never
use alts. That being said, haha, Casey Tron and Jtock back to
back. This is my finest day. That's his employee on one of his
platforms when I got banned. Which, by the way, that's annoying.
But I didn't ask for him to get removed for that. I didn't even
ask for anything to happen because of that. What am I supposed
to get mad that people don't like me? Imagine being that thin
skinned. But like
apparently, you know, anybody celebrating this, that's proof
that we wanted it to happen or we we made it happen. That seems
like complete like the celebrated. I mean I Yeah, I get >> If
they said if they said we got him, then I would be snatched.
>> Terminated is banning YouTube pretty sure. Let's go
like like this. Do you notice Connor how that's like literally
not at all what happened there? Not what was said. >> Do
you notice that? Like how are people dude I keep saying how are
people not embarrassed by this? But if you just look at the concurrent
viewership for the past couple days, I feel like people are starting
to get embarrassed by this. No, I mean people are starting to
get embarrassed. They're starting to be like a h this is kind
of like garbage. I'm I'm out. Yeah. I mean, I could ask for more
logs from shots, but yeah, they celebrate this and they all do
it. Yeah.
>> Uh, do I have my own logs? Should I pull up my logs?
Because I think I literally said in the chat like, "Yeah, I I'm
upset this happened." Like, I I don't like that that happened.
Right. >> Okay. So, go ahead. >> No, no, no, no.
Um, I >> Oh, this guy right here, food stamps played a
clip where the epsler can be heard multiple times. Is that to
on YouTube? They do, but it'll always be stuff like this where
cuz then I don't know if that's for my community. >> I
was watching that. I basically don't I just don't really I'm
not a reporting kind of person in general is up. But >> but
even more what because I guess like the you doing this when you
debate like justical and you ask questions about this. He'll
what he'll sell what he'll tell you is he'll go oh really show
me in our chat where we said report this person. Show me you'll
no I'll say show me the evidence you have for why you believe
this. He's just lying. What evidence do you have to believe this?
I'm not saying you have to show me a precise thing. He did this
to Pisco as well. Remember when he gaslit Pisco and was like,
"You asked me for a precise clip." No, I'm saying why do you
believe this? Can you just show me why you believe this at all?
Right. Just show me why you believe it. But he did it Pisco,
too. He just lied about like how specific people are asking um
how specific of evidence people are asking for. I'm literally
just trying to have a conversation with a lot of people who think
this cuz I know I'm in the right. If I'm just n nice and understanding
with people, I know I'm in the right. I know they'll see it.
I know they'll understand. Doesn't he also do this exact same
stuff but more explicit when he asked for clips to get you banned?
Yep. 100% he did that. Yep. Would he not ask for timestamps precisely
for my to get me banned? I'm pretty confident he did. Yes. Then
he goes to his platforms which are far larger and tries to get
me banned from you'll never find it and then you auto lose on
all the debates and that's why people get like gassed on >> Also
appeal to how bad these people are. So, for instance, they could
probably do this with me quite simply. >> Um, if food chops
was unrepentant
about a moral issue on which we disagree, they would be like,
"Oh, well, doesn't she do this or aren't you happy that she's
banned?"
>> You know, so so they would appeal to my >> Sure.
Maybe eventually. Yeah. Or if you you can't defend principally
any concept because they'll accuse you of supporting the worst
of the accusations. >> Yeah. What the happened to, by the
way, sorry, this is just like a frustrating thing. What happened
to I have my morals that I live by and you have your morals that
you live by
and if we share a political project or share a project, we can
work on the shared vision of the project, but you live by your
morals, I live by my morals. What the [__] happened
to that? Cuz I thought >> that's not you're just under
Okay, so Andrew Tate being a part of the conservative movement
is a huge positive then. So, as long as we're clear, that's fine.
I thought I thought the whole point was you have certain morals
that like are red lines for you. I thought he outlined this and
one of his red lines was doxing like two years ago. God, >> how
adult human beings operate. >> You're you're playing a
different game. This is what people I've said this to Democrats
versus Republicans. You're just you have to understand you're
playing a different game. >> What game am I playing and
what game are they playing?
>> All he has to say is why his morals change. But when
he says, "Oh, my morals change." He's like he's going I'm doing
a pragmatic analysis that's like, "Well, we could do more good
with Destiny." which is wrong. By the way, this is an incorrect
analysis, but he's doing that pragmatic analysis. And he's uh
he's come to the conclusion that >> actually if I just
don't enforce my morals, that's better for the world. Lots of
people do that. Rarely works. Okay? Rarely works. Usually, you
just end up getting chewed up and spit up by some machine that's
convincing you it was okay to give your morals up in the first
place. You're playing some kind of politics or whatever game
and they're playing like the social pressure game. It's a different
thing. They have different goals. It's like if we were to argue
over and over again like what the best car is and you want to
win a race and I just like the color blue. Sometimes we might
agree if they're really fast blue cars, but other times I'm going
to choose like the Prius because it's blue and I like it and
you're going to be scratching your head trying to figure out
what the [__] is going on. This is what I was saying
in the beginning where like some criticism you said, "How can
we hold our own to account without, you know, uh >> without
burning the bridges?" >> Yeah. And it's and I said this
very easy. You just tell people, "Hey, you [__] up.
Don't [__] up again. Like we'll figure it out." Or
if you're going to keep [__] up, you know, we cut
ties or whatever. But these people, you can tell that's not the
goal of any of this, right? The goal is not to hold people accountable.
By the way, Connor, I still think Connor believes that doxing
is bad. He could engage in this very easily. Hey, Destiny, if
you dox Doobie, I'm walking,
right? He could he could lay that out. If you dox Doobie for
nothing other than like basically disagreeing with you, think
you're a piece of I'm done. Right? If he wanted to actually enforce
his morals here, if he wanted to do what Destiny's saying, right?
The issue is it doesn't matter what kind of piece of [__]
Destiny is. These people all make excuses for it all the time.
Their spines are flexible and their sp their spines are flexible
because they're going to make money off of it. I I understand
like I know where they're coming from. I just it it feels like
uh if I'm not getting the money, I should at least get to call
it out, right? If I'm not getting the money from that, I should
get to call it out. Come on. The goal is not to like do something
righteous or good or virtuous. I said that as much when I was
responding to Ethan about Willie. Like if Willie would have told
me privately, he's like, "Hey, you told me be really uncomfortable.
Like I'm like even or even if he didn't tell me to be depressed
like I had to call somebody at the FBI like say some [__]
I'd be like I got it. That's fine. I understand that. But like
there's a difference between that and like I what
so
is not actually mad about the FBI getting called. He's mad about
Willie publicizing it. And he I feel like he's not even mad about
Willie publicizing it from the angle that it up the investigation
cuz obviously telling him privately would the investigation up.
He's mad that Willie gave him the ability for other people to
like criticize Destiny on the things he told Willie.
That's transparent, isn't it? That like you still lose the investigation.
You still harm the investigation if he tells Destiny, right?
In private. But he's like, I wouldn't even be mad at you if you
just told me in private, will he? Isn't that a little child between
friends? Isn't that something that could stay between friends,
Willie? Come on, man. Come on, >> Like, hold on. Okay.
Detective. Like that's this is that's you're playing a totally
different game at that point, right? You and that's what I'm
saying is that so you're asking like well how can we have these
conversations? You can't they're after something fundamentally
different. They're not looking for reform or you you you guys
all catch that, right? That he's just made it very clear that
his actual problem with Willie
is that Willie like publicized this not it's not from the compromises
the investigation angle. It's published it to hurt Desty's reputation.
That's
that's the actual transgression here. That's nuts to just come
out and say that directly >> or to build like some coalition
politically. They're just want to have like a social game. >> Am
I Well, I I think the answer I think I have to go down with my
own ship though. I I think I'm
>> You know, uh Quimman was kind of laughing about this.
He's like uh and I'll use a direct quote. He was like, "Oh, Connor
was our inside guy with the PV drama." You know, he kept telling
us things that we shouldn't know. And I was thinking to myself
like during that it's like no I was telling you the truth like
I wasn't you know like like yeah I have a side and I care about
my side >> but in so far as I can possibly tell the truth
if you ask me a question I'm going to tell the truth.
>> Do you know what those guys say about PV now though?
>> Like Queen just >> Well, isn't it like the >> Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. Is he going to say some insane about
what I think about PV that's not even remotely true? You want
to know something funny? Okay, you want to know something really
funny? When I was talking to Wick and Counterpoints, they're
both on my stream. I'll have to go back and check the logs and
try to line them up with the date. You know who was DMing me
questions for Wick to show that Wick was being kind of about
the PV stuff? It was Destiny.
Destiny was sending me questions through DMs of like, "Ask Wick
this next. Ask try to ask Wick this." Now, the funny thing was
I asked Wick those questions and then Destiny jumped on to defend
Wick from those questions or like some in some downstream conversation
like jumped on to start protecting Wick.
It was the weirdest thing I've ever like seen. It was very bizarre.
It was just it was very weird,
which is fine. Like I I didn't really care, but it was just it
was interesting to me that that's But like he had he had a lot
of reservations about PV. I think he had a lot of reservations
about PV and now he's like, "Oh, can do you know what just say
about PV now?" I would love to hear this
cuz I have a feeling based on what he said that where I agree
with Hassan entirely um on the chorus stuff. I just assume he
has no idea what I actually think. >> Dark money preview
to the Taylor the Ren. Jessica literally comparing the chorus
tenant media and every to
I've actually I think I said the tenant stuff is like not a good
comparison cuz people will just go that it was foreign money
so it's automatically bad
>> but the in terms of the funding and how it was like
being spent yeah the the carry committee setup is like yeah it's
like pretty close
I by the way
don't think either of those things are inherently evil I totally
disagree with that framing that other people do. So like these
are not people who have
>> well can can somebody like so so I had this conversation
with Becket a while ago and and I had this conversation with
Becket last last night not specifically about PV but I had a
conversation with >> and his point with the PV thing was
if it's not disclosed then you don't understand people's biases
and so they can be acting like they're they're acting from like
a an integrated principled position but they're biased by money
which is why you should disclose where your money comes from.
>> Come on.
>> Is this Dude, I
>> You hear me? Yes or no? Okay, so we
>> They don't even edit this out. This was only a couple
hours ago. There's no time to edit it out. >> So, I probably
got like another 20 >> Okay. Okay. Go ahead. >> Um,
so what I was saying was
uh the politics game. Um I don't know if people caught that but
effectively like
um Queman said like oh he was our inside man he was telling us
secrets we weren't supposed to know any of that and all that
kind of stuff but it was like no I was just telling you the truth
as I understood it and also if you have like let I'm working
for an institution right but let's say that and that institution
is paying me but we are aligned on goals as far as what we want
to achieve in the >> what's the problem >> and I
think that this It's the heart of the Taylor the Rens drama where
realistically like people don't believe me. They genuinely just
don't believe me.
A Democratic organization named Pavey reached out to me. They
said, "Hey, you're in the Twitch and YouTube politics scene.
We need uh a Republican to be a part of our organization. We
see I think this is intentional for Pavey. I think to claim you're
nonpartisan, you do need like some Republican point of view like
to do the because I think to have this exact designation, you
need to be nonpartisan like and possibly some form of nonpolitical,
right? I So when people are like, well, look, we have somebody
who doesn't agree with the Democrats. We're not Democrat. It's
like, dude, you are so full of which again, I just don't like
being lied to. Just don't tell me you're not partisan.
Just don't tell me that. Just just you don't have to make a different
video that I cannot watch where I don't have to watch you lie.
Don't treat me like a lie to me. Okay. >> I know that you
think that Trump is [__] bad and going to be a disaster
for this country. Would you want to work together in order to
help bring alt media into real world politics and god >> and
do you want to help? Shut up. >> No, you're describing
lobbying,
>> I guess. So, they're just as what you're saying because
the argument that I make a lot. people have this understanding
that lobbying is this nefarious thing where these buy but in
reality people just support people and provide epistemic resources
to people who already agree with them basically like Apac is
not turning people into Israel supporters they just find people
that they feel like supports Israel and then they throw some
money at their campaign >> well and not just that I'm sure
that they give them like talking points >> that's not all
that it is though
it the issue is okay you support Israel Apac backs you
commits an atrocity
now
You're sitting there, oh, I kind of won my last election based
off of Apac being like 50% of my funding. Am I going to be 100%
honest in my criticisms of Israel now that I've gotten that money?
I did agree with them, but they've pushed it a little further,
right? They pushed they've they've become a little less supportable.
And maybe am I going to speak my conscience or am I going to,
you know, do the calculation that Connor did and say, I could
do more good in the world if I keep my seat and I can actually
have a finger here and I'm I'm not as compromised as some of
the other people here, right? >> Some resources. Yeah.
Hey, people are are coming at you for like this stuff, but like
this is what we would say about >> you used a 14 letter
word, so that's okay. I do that sometimes. The Okay, so so the
point is like
>> this cuts to the heart of the Taylor Ren's drama where
you could argue something about disclosure. You could argue something
about transparency or some. What the is the problem with Democrats
incubating
Democratic or liberal creators to spread a Democratic or liberal
message in this political atmosphere. And not just that, half
these people who we're talking about in the drama and commentary
space. >> Literally no problem with this whatsoever. As
I've stated like a thousand times,
just don't like being lied to.
They identify as either liberals or
Who? This is They're just doing the Hassan thing. Why are you
guys getting so mad at me? I just support free healthcare. I
just want universal healthcare. Why are you getting so mad at
me? It's cuz of the other you're lying about.
Sorry, Ogre Boy. I'm sorry you had to hear that, Ogre Boy. Okay.
I I'm sorry you had to hear that. But yes. Yeah, I know. Willie
Mack dropped a new video. We'll probably check it out. Uh guys,
don't forget if you want the stream to go for longer, we are
two subs away from another hour on the stream. All right, two
subs away from another hour. I guess you just don't want to help
Democrats win. It's like, yeah, I just don't want to. You're
just lying. By the way, like don't don't slide to Taylor Loren's
and just point out the actual problems with the article.
She was too hyperbolic in like these two places.
You don't have to you don't have to lie about her. You don't
have to say she's a hypocrite cuz she took dark money with no
evidence. You don't have to do any of that. You don't have to
tell me that your your chorus media group has no alignment at
all with the Democratic party. You don't have to tell me that.
Just shut the [__] up. Don't lie to me. That's all
I want. Just don't lie to me.
It's like so crazy. But instead, when I when I say I just don't
want to be lied to, they're like, "Oh, so you just you just don't
want Democrats to win. You just want like a third term of Trump,
I
>> Yeah. Give me a second. I'm >> talking about in
the drama and commentary space. They identify as either liberals
or progressives.
>> They identify as being on the left. What the is your
Why is this a crabs in a bucket situation? So there's >> slicing
the legs out of your the people who are propagandizing on your
behalf. >> So we don't have time to go into this right
now. We don't. We can in the future though. Maybe I won't future
debates. There's a lot of things going on here that I've realized
now, especially over the past few days. One, the whole concept
of dark money is actually [__] stupid. There's no
such thing as dark money unless you literally
No, actually there's no such thing as dark money. >> I
mean, Rathon sending me money in an offshore bank account. I
think that's dark money. But that doesn't even make sense because
they would never send you that money unless you knew that they
were sending you that money. >> I know. I'm >> Yeah.
Well, no, no, but people actually make that argument, right?
>> And also, Rathon, you can send me money. >> Yeah.
So, one, I actually don't even believe in dark money as a concept
now. Um, and I think that it's been a weird bastardization of
the problems with Citizens United. People keep hyperfixating
on this concept that Citizens United was bad because of like
dark money, dark money, dark money. [__] dark money.
Who cares about dark money? The problem is because of the way
the 501c4s work and these 5287s work. I think 527 530. The problem
is that you can put an unlimited amount of money towards certain
issues. And they you're not supposed to be for a politician,
but they basically are. That's the issue. It wouldn't matter
if Jeff Bezos could give $5,000 of dark money because that's
the FEC limit to some campaign. The issue is when he can spend
$50 million without any This is literally the precise problem
that we have.
This is literally like precisely he's describing the exact issue
when we say PV and and chorus overlap. It's because of the same
problem with not knowing the source of the money or how much
is there or what the it's like all of the same things. There's
so many things that are overlapping here. I don'tbody knowing
on some issue with that. The big issue with super PACs is the
unlimited per individual spending. That's the big deal. Number
one. So or kind of tied in number. So this concept of dark money
is stupid in my opinion. No, not in my opinion. It's stupid because
the big criticism that Taylor has is these guys are taking money
from dark money does not refer to just so we're clear, dark money
does not refer to whether or not they disclose that they're getting
paid. That's not what dark money means. Morris and one of their
donors is um what is it the 1630 fund? Yep. >> How the
is that dark money? Because it's get they're getting paid by
chorus to do a job and one of course or maybe chorus
because the 1630 fund is a dark money fund. It's a I assume a
501c4,
right?
Or wait, did I say 1630? Yeah, 1630 fund. It might not be a 501c4.
I actually don't know. It might not be. It is literally a 501c4.
I
I feel like I'm being gaslit.
>> There's 1630. Where's the dark money? Is it Do I have
to know every single person that comes into 1630? Let's say that
I wanted to sponsor you if I don't publicly disclose all of my
income sources. Is me paying you? Is that dark money? 16:30 is
literally >> not if it's on my taxes.
>> That's it's
so this whole dark money concept is stupid as >> the Okay.
the impropriety or the opaque nature of the allegations is the
fact that allegedly which by the way I haven't seen like within
the contract where it says this >> but they said uh allegedly
that the there's four funders who provided 70% of the funding
of the
1630 whatever thing >> and they were saying that as chorus
>> don't mention chorus unless you mention us in this specific
regard and do not talk about our funders. Now, that's all he
hearsay. >> I would be careful. Yeah, because Taylor's
lies at least 10 plus times in that article. >> But like,
>> okay, name the lies. Where are the lies >> there?
So, people keep sending me >> there are there are I mean,
I would call it stretching, right? It's like
I wouldn't say there's 10 out I don't I don't think it's possible
that there are 10 outright lies in that article. the clip of
the article that says that, but they don't say, "We have a copy
of a Skype call." >> Well, she says she has copies of today,
but she doesn't say, "We have a copy of the contract." >> Yeah,
she has said that.
why won't he say the actual allegation?
Don't trust Wired because they lie. Do not trust Wired
because they lie is what he needs to be saying. It's not saying
Taylor Loren reviewed these contracts and this is what happened.
It says the Wired editorial staff reviewed these contracts, right?
So, accuse the publication of publishing lies. Do not accuse
Taylor Loren of lying. Do not try to use Taylor Lorenz's uh reputation
because it's not her reputation that's going to be on the line
if it if we find out that Wire didn't actually vet these >> Well,
but then show me in the contract saying that we can't talk about
>> that because she's lying. >> Well, then at that
point, I would say her and [__] everybody who's fallen
for it. on top of that, dude. >> So again, I I know that
Destiny's not dumb enough to have not understood what it means
when wired when it says wired editorial staff based on contracts
reviewed by the wired editorial staff or whatever the he knows
exactly what it means, right? Why is Connor
Why is Connor so dumb?
God, he's like the one person who will actually like talk to
Destiny in any sort of negative way. Listen, this is the best
they can do. Okay, this is the least sick ofantic person. He's
still a massive sickopant, but why does he have to be so dumb,
too? He's like right there. He could just ask like one more question.
It' be so easy. >> I'm sorry if you're getting about it,
but like we are projected to kill 14 million people over the
next 5 years through incompetence by slashing PEPAR and slashing
US ID. And by the way, the projections could be off by 90% and
we would still kill 1.5 million people through incompetence through
preventable
>> that's [__] up by itself. >> I agree.
>> Add another 20 crimes of Trump. Why the do we give a
[__] about Democrats working with Democrats in order
to forward Democrat causes? >> Wait, why?
>> Why do people care? No, no, no. Why do people care?
>> Okay, give me 5 seconds. I think the leftists and the
progressives
want to bully the liberals so they can take a larger market share
of the Democratic
>> Yes. So then what you have to understand is none of
>> all I think we all agree that some amount of Taylor
Lorenz's uh what would you call it? um motivation was that I'm
mad that this group is going to issue like some of the more progressive
people that I like. I'm kind of annoyed about it.
Some amount of this was driven by that. Okay, you can tell from
her Glenn Greenwald interview that some amount of her motivation
for this article was because of that. Okay, that doesn't mean
you get to lie about her. That doesn't mean you get to lie to
me. That doesn't mean you get to lie to the people who like follow
you, who follow your creators. Stop
lying.
of this is about making Democrats stronger. None of this is about
giving good or transparency. None. Because Taylor Lens and all
these people accept dark money too. If if that's how you define
it, 100
does. Okay. Um his his thread literally proved nothing. It's
just garbled garbage. Is the thread he did total. Uh I'm starting
to think that not unlike Willy Mack, did Destiny have like a
ghostriter before? Cuz I swear to God, since the allegations
came out, he's gotten dumber. And I'm starting to think he might
have actually had a ghostriter before
because he does that whole thread where he shows that in 2022,
I think the Omdar Network Services LLC accepted $45,000
from the 1630 fund.
And that LLC doesn't work back up into the Omdar Group and down
to the Journalist Without Borders, whatever the that program
is called, right? Journalism residence program. and Omidar came
out and said no part of the 1630 fund has ever touched that money
right till Lorenz is objectively not taking that dark money but
they don't deal with reality they just are good with lying I
don't know why and then because she's accepted money from that
Ahmed yeah whatever fund which funds itself also with a hybrid
structure and a 501c4 which is dark money that's why she considers
it dark money because a 1630 fund is the same thing right so
it's not about any of that it's just about destroying
it's just about destroying people who are part of the Democratic
party It's >> uh they might be a 501c4 and they might fund
themselves the same way. Uh they're allowed to disclose if they
want to, right? I think
I would just love to see where is the where is the Omidar funds
coming from cuz if if she's getting it from a 501c4 and the funding
is non-transparent, then I would say it's dark money. But I've
not seen that argument. This not argument he made or wasn't the
argument he made. It's a 501c3, not a 501c4.
Okay. Can you hide the funders with a 501c3 in the same way?
Because I
hold on. C3s do not have to disclose. I know Midar is literally
the name of the billionaire. That's what I said. 501c3s have
to disclose.
C4s don't have to disclose. C3s I thought do have to disclose.
So, is he just lying here blatantly? Okay. Well, cool. When criticizes
me, is not trying to like make me a better person or have me
held accountable or whatever. He just wants to destroy me and
my career, right?
>> I'm just sitting here calmly analyzing how he's making
things up >> because he hates Taylor Loren's.
How about we just Google it? Well, I don't really have to Google
it. That was already my understanding.
Media Network has to publicly file with the IRS. GG.
I I'm sorry. I'm just sitting here and like I'm just like I just
like knowing the truth on things.
I even said, "Oh, if they are a 501c4, they fund themselves the
same way and they're a 501c4 and that 501c4 feeds down into the
journalist program that she's in, then you can make that argument."
I literally said I just lay it out conditionally.
>> Better person >> when um better than him. Yeah.
But I mean like I'm also like 200 lb lighter. But like and then
when Trump or when any of the Republicans are criticizing people
on the >> It's cuz he's like 4 foot five. He's 200 lb lighter
than the average person. >> Left, right? They're not trying
to make
Uh, listen. I I think the face reveal is coming soon. Okay. We'll
we'll see better. When somebody says Gavin Newsome shouldn't
be tweeting like that, it's very unbecoming. Do they want him
to be a better governor? No, they're asking. >> No, they
want him to stop tweeting. >> Yeah, because they're holding
because he's only going to be Trump, right? So, one of the things
you have to be mindful of, I think, is where the criticism comes
from because that'll tell you what it's supposed to do. Taylor
Lorent in her article. I would argue that the way that she writes
as a form of doxing because when she does articles and you should
go back and reread it or read it if you haven't. She is very
big on naming everybody that she can. >> Oh yeah. First
name, last name, city >> and well not even maybe city but
she'll name the people and their socials so that you can punish
them and hold them accountable. Okay. Uh, listen, I could probably
go along with some form of this argument that Keller Ren, I wouldn't
be shocked if when she is covering people from a negative lens
that she could name things where if she doesn't like people,
she will give more information out than she has to. I think that
could be true. I think there's probably an argument for like
what information needs to be disclosed based on a public interest.
I would need to see an example of that. I don't trust Destiny
to to lay that out really, but I could see that being true. I
think based on her doxing the uh what is it libs of Tik Tok I
can see that probably being true. No I sorry with this allegation
I would give charity to this allegation in in just in the form
of I think there's probably an allegation here that she goes
beyond
just the public interest in revealing information that if it's
somebody bad she'll reveal more information than she has to so
that she she so that she can be um like punitive to those people.
I think so. I think I've heard about this in the past. I think
this is sort of the veiled justification she used to dox libs
of Tik Tok, right?
So like I do think I know about that.
And yeah, I have criticism for that. I'm not a huge fan of that.
Hold on. No, you're supposed to blindly support Loren to despite
to spite Destiny.
I just don't like the lies. The lies about her are just goofy.
They make you look stupid. Anyway,
so if you read her article, that um chorus article, it was a
hit piece 100%. Every claim was negative. There was nothing positive
about it. Basically, every major claim was either incorrect or
was just inconsequential, was just stupid, right? But that's
not true either. And there were
obviously not being able to disclose this is kind of bad. Seems
kind of bad. A lot of the rolling their network into yours is
like kind of parasitic. I I don't like it as much. Maybe parasite
is not the right word because they're you're paying them, but
like uh I just I'm not a fan of like, oh, we need all of your
contacts with these people that you talk to. Not a huge fan.
Okay. >> Numerous. There were at least five huge contradictions
of the article. I went there to run it on. Also the her
>> is he just going to uh I might have to go watch his
on it at some point and see if I can find his the big contradictions
that he has laid out >> at the end wasn't um we just think
it would be good of course publish the contracts or we think
it would be good for they said that at the end they quoted that
v Safar whatever who said I think that it would just be better
to donate to creators directly whatever stupid statement what
the does that mean and then the >> I mean I agree you should
super chat and then also going back to the third point I was
going to say I had one Two, three. Speaking of donating to creators
directly, guys, we're one sub away from another hour. Uh, if
we can get 10 subs, I'll add two more hours. Okay, 10 subs, two
more hours.
We got to get it before the uh before the 30 minutes, before
15 minutes have gone by. If we get 10 subs, we'll do two more
hours. >> That'll be the Willy Mac video, and it'll be
something else. We'll see what else we're going to do. >> One
was um uh cuz it was like the Stark money. I don't even think
it's real. Doesn't matter. Whatever. um was why do people pretend
like being funded by an >> There's one placebo 98. Thank
you very
>> Makes you more dependent on them or it makes you more
susceptible to some kind of marketing ploy than audience capture
because I would argue to some extent independent funding I think
even you maybe realize this independent funding can keep you
more uh independent than audience capture. Audience capture can
keep you incredibly locked in on certain topics or certain political
opinions.
>> Uh, wow. Wow. Shsky, thank you for the five. Let's go.
That's six. We need four more, guys. Four more in the next what,
15 minutes and we'll do two more hours. >> And by the way,
like some people
>> There's a big five right away. Oh my
>> Oh my god.
French toast Mafia. Thank you for the five. And Shulk
Shulk, thank you for the gifted sub. Appreciate you. Let's go,
guys. That's going to be all of the time for the rest of the
stream. We can just end all the timers and stuff. We've got the
full eight hours. Let's go.
Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. All right. All right. >> With
me or
>> um Oh, he's saying that like audience capture. Yeah,
audience capture could be bad. Sure, audience capture could be
bad. The issue with Do you see the Bret Cooper? The Bret Cooper
video seems to be mostly about uh his his relationship with Nathan.
I don't really want to go through it. I saw a little bit of it.
Uh it's funny that it's getting talked, but I just I try not
to focus on that. You know, little snide comment here or there
is the deepest we want to go in that topic. Um shake shake. Okay.
Okay. So, here's the difference. Okay. Yeah. $8,000 a month.
As you become more dependent on that specific funding source,
you become more likely to compromise for that specific funding
source. It's already difficult when you have an oiler who's doing
like 10% or 20% of your like monthly budget or your monthly income.
Okay, that's already difficult to like say you would ban them
if they're doing bad [__] right? Obviously, the level
of funding $8,000 a month, that's crazy for most creators, especially
like Tik Tok creators. Okay. Yeah. Audience, you can have audience
capture. You can get pulled in the direction by audience capture.
That's for sure. If I wanted to really
control a bunch of creators, right, I feel like audience capture
and just individual donations would be a better way to do it
if you had a lot of uh resources to do that, right?
But man, I don't know. I don't know that you could really compare
it in the same way with no other
>> than audience capture. Audience capture can keep you
incredibly locked in on certain topics or political opinions.
>> I see. And and by the way, like some people disagree
with me or whatever, but I I think that you can only there's
half a dozen creators who are like uh Trump
>> I think that if you look at their principles from 10
years ago, the only way that they you can arrive at who they
are now, >> Connor, for the love of God, Connor,
please don't say some that absolutely applies to you. Please
don't say some that applies to you in the most haunting of ways.
Please, for the love of God, Connor, do not look at the ghost
of Christmas future right now, Connor. >> through audience
capture, the only way that they you can arrive at who they are
now is through audience capture. >> 100%. You and I have
one mutual friend. >> Which one? >> Who had that
issue of locked in audience capture stuff? I don't think they
do content anymore. I think they just released a book. >> Who
the are we talking about? Sorry, I'm being silent because Connor
apparently doesn't understand that Lauren Southern's basically
like one of like four mutuals they have.
I I don't even know, dude. I don't even know, man.
>> Not D Laguna.
>> I think she just released a book.
>> Wait, is it Day Laguna? Who the [__] >> No,
he doesn't know. He literally doesn't know.
>> Tell me about the rabbits again, Stephen. Tell me about
the farm. Tell me about the farm, Stephen.
Will there be bunnies, Stephen? Jesus Christ. But yeah, like
my good friend LS. >> Yeah. Um, Last Shadow is what I think
he used to go by in the Starcraft world. Um, but yeah, like there
are people who you go down a certain road >> and it's really
hard to course correct at all. >> It's No, it's a in my
opinion, it's a gilded cage. And what I mean by that is you make
cash, your cage is beautiful, you know, it's it's lined with
gold, but you're stuck inside it. And and that's where I do feel
bad for LS uh that story screamer streamer um and several other
center-right contrarian creators who effectively in my opinion,
they might not even agree with me. Sure. But from >> and
I'm not implying there's a bunch of people who are totally
morally bankrupt, selling out like don't believe it at all, but
just that like they might take a slightly different direction.
might
>> bro. I I like I just laugh. I don't think I could be
any more transparent in my positions like on Twitter and it's
just like it throws me off that like I'm just being very clear
that like no issue with chorus funding leftwing creators and
trying to create an ecosystem. My more serious concerns with
chorus have been the seemingly coordinated response to the article,
right? And I list out like the the actual problems I have, none
of which are even dark money.
And then I just get like told I'm agreeing with the song. It
feels it feels weird. >> Anyway, talk about some things
a little bit less or a little bit more I'll try to I'll try to
complain less when I do >> I would they would be more spicy
and more independent if they knew that they weren't going to
lose 10 to 20% of their audience as a result. >> Yeah.
So, yeah. So, this idea so I would even challenge and a lot of
what I've just said I'm challenging a lot of truisms. These are
just supposed to be things people take for granted like oh having
a single funer that's bad. You should donate to creators directly.
That's the thing that people just they think that's a good thing.
That's kind
>> uh Pisco talk when? Um might be a chance to talk to
Bisco at some point.
I could like look at it, see if I could talk to Bisco about it.
The funny thing is is I think I basically I think outside of
like some window dressing in terms of what we actually think
the solutions are. I think Pisco and I align like 95%.
So it's funny that it seems like we might disagree like massively.
I don't think that's the case >> necessarily a good thing.
And every creator knows that the whole idea about dark money
being bad, is it bad? I don't know if that's true. If somebody
comes up to me and they give me a bunch of money, if my political
opinions aren't changing or anything, like I don't know like
would that matter? >> Well, I mean that was my argument
for the for the PV because at the same time like I never said,
oh, Karma's amazing. She's the best thing since sliced bread.
I said she's the lesser. She's the clear lesser of two evils
within this moral calculus. And if you don't see that, you're
a idiot. Yeah. So that that is actually not contradictory to
anything I've said for the past 5 or 10 years. >> The thing
that I think is important one is the law is important in so far
as um like far should be respected. You can't take like foreign
money, right? >> If you're representing those foreign interests,
you should disclose. >> So I think like the laws I think
in place there are really important uh number one. And then number
two, I think if people have highly sus or questionable
um like position changes, then I think that that can be looked
>> They need to be explained.
>> that that's my thing. So So for >> but let's real
quick like let's say I found out tomorrow that let's say that
I found out that Hassan was taking a million dollars a month
fromQatar or whatever. Well, they'd have to disclose that. Let's
assume it wasn't. You didn't have to. It was it was legal to
do that. Let's say I found that out. I don't know if that would
change much of my commentary at all on him because all of the
arguments are so it's all so stupid. I would still fight basically
the same way. I might point out, oh wow, look at you, you're
getting a fat pocket for doing this, but he also gets a pretty
penny from shilling for the prop pallet crowd from his audience,
right? So it's like yeah, so there are a lot of truisms that
go along with like the dark money thing that I would actually
but this is like a nobody's thought about these arguments and
they would be really triggered hearing them the first time around.
So my uh
where I apply some degree of latitude is explanations. So So
for instance, like if you change your perspective, let's say,
you know, I don't know, you're a pro-Russian show one day and
then switch to Ukraine. Yeah. >> But you explain how your
>> Sorry, I just saw Willie change his uh his title. >> The
Destiny situation is unhinged. Scorch Earth has now become Destiny's
unironically stupid. Lawyers, it's over.
>> So, I just I noticed that change and I wanted to point
that out to you guys. >> You're like, >> let's keep
going. >> You know, my family grew up in Russia. I bought
into some of the Putin propaganda. I read Alexander Dugan. I
thought he was brilliant. Um, but then I actually started talking
to my Ukrainian family and they explained like everything that
they were going through as a result of Russia and I realized
like actually, you know what, Ukraine is in the right in this.
Then I would be like, "Oh, okay. Who gives a shit?" Like, you
change your mind, but you change your mind off of articulable
evidence. Whereas if somebody flips on a dime and they have no
explanation, then I'm like, "Oh,
either you're you realize that this is where your audience was
and you did not want to alienate your audience or you're taking
cash from someone and you you know,
there has to be an explanatory value for a ma massive shift or
contradiction in principle." >> Yeah. Yeah. >> And
I'm able to articulate all of mine, which is one of the things
where I get frustrated where people are like, "Hey, you've changed
all your principles." And I'm like, "Name one." >> Yeah.
And then it's like and then yeah like okay fine like are we going
to be in this world where
like I want to see all of your income sources then how does Taylor
Lawrence make all her money?
>> So why the should they know anything else about anybody
else right? Like why should anybody know >> that's your
rabid capitalist coming out >> What do you mean? Well,
where I think
uh media creators so so for instance like if um Sagur and Jetty
and Crystal >> if they were taking loads of money from
Cotter I would want to know that because they have like a pretty
strong
uh
uni party
uh Israel
>> Sagal
Sagal >> bad you know slant to their news while >> oh
I just did the accent and I just realized actually that I I need
to go over to uh r/ chase talk. There is somebody who like listen
I have some some actual people in this audience uh about the
increased hate towards Indian men. I should read this at some
point on stream.
I do feel bad
I feel bad cuz I've got some people in the community who are
actually like nice people who are Indian. I know that sucks.
It sucks.
Anyway, >> still pretending that they're independent. And
so if they were taking $100 million from Carter or $10 million
from Cotter, I would want to know if that was a substantive part
of their funding because I would realize that they're catering
to that bias.
>> Yeah, that's possible. Their arguments would still be
because they are they are what they are. But like I just I actually
feel bad cuz I know a bunch of uh Okay, off Cherry
off.
Uh I just feel bad. I realize that it could be a troll. Okay,
I realize it could be a troll. I just feel bad because uh I actually
do know some Indian people from like DG generally. I've had like
a lot of co-workers who have been Indian Indian Canadians and
they've all been like really good people. So, >> but I'm
just saying like but I'm just saying that if we if we need to
know like chorus like the fact that these people are funded by
chorus and it's not enough to know that they're funded by chorus.
We have to know that they're funded by chorus um via the 1630
fund but it's not enough to know that they're funded by chorus
via the 1630 fund. We have to know who funds the 1630 fund. And
then I >> I don't think anybody's making this argument.
Is Taylor Maybe Taylor's making this argument. Maybe
um I don't make this argument. And I have no problem with with
people saying, "Hey, I think it's really crazy."
Although, did did Taylor not say that like I understand this
a part of the
Bro, it's like there's just so many things here where it's like
really obvious that uh
like there's not a lot of push back from people. I'm again I'm
I'm going to say that response to this is what has actually kind
of killed me more than almost anything else. I guess who funds
the indiv because like again people are so brainwashed on the
dark money thing. You'll read I reading the Taylor Lens article.
There was a part where she's like um four mega donors gave however
much money to this blah blah blah blah blah and they donated
um mainly to back it was like anti-abortion pro-choice. It was
pro No. >> Yeah. What's the problem? >> No no no.
But it wasn't that. It was she said like they donated to for
pro-choice causes. Um they donated for to fight for this on the
ballot over this and nobody knows what their interests are. And
it's like [__] >> those are the four interest.
>> Those are the interests. You just >> Isn't Taylor's
network paid by the 1630 fund? No. No. And they they took $45,000
in 2022. Taylor says it was a refund for other services or something.
I have no idea that that's true. It's pretty obvious that for
what Taylor's doing now, they are not taking money from the 1630
fund. The Omidia Network themselves actually put out a statement
saying, "No, they're not taking money from the 1630 fund." This
is just factually incorrect. It's incorrect in every possible
way.
But people will just run with this lie. People are continuing
to run with this lie. It's very sad. You >> said it. Yeah.
What are you talking
>> But this is these are like very different from the articles.
Like you're literally explaining it in the what their interests
are. Like what else? And this is why I'm saying >> another
nefarious thing they're up. >> Yeah. And I'm like what
are we talking about here? Dude, >> I will say that I believe
Pierro Midiar must be one of the major contributors to the 1630
fund and possibly even Chorus
because when Brian Tyler Cohen makes his rebuttal to Taylor Loren,
he doesn't say that she's funded by dark money,
he says that Taylor Lens is funded by somebody who also funds
the 1630 fund, which is just interesting to me. >> This
is why I'm saying the concept is so stupid. They're like, "Well,
you >> Yes. So that's $40,000 Internet Ray that they took
in 2022.
You understand that, right? That that LLC took $40,000
in 2022. And I believe that LLC is somehow
I think it is Oh, let's look at the Omidar
uh statement again. So our programmatic our programmatic work
is supported entirely via our foundation and LLC. So is this
the Omidar Network LLC?
It took $45,000. So it's not funded by 1630. Maybe you could
argue that it could be funded by dark money if that was coming
entirely out of the LLC. I believe that the 1630, sorry, I believe
that Omidar has to report some of the stuff already. I do wonder
where the um reporters and residents program, like if you looked
at all of that, right? I wonder where that funding would come
from. LLC's don't disclose publicly.
Uh okay, LLC's don't disclose publicly.
Sure, possibly.
But they do disclose, right? As in that is tracked by like the
the IRS. I believe it has oversight. Unless I'm missing something.
Anyway, we continue. Well, I don't
>> We can go back to chorus stuff at some point in the
near future. >> Who the
when people talk about dark money, they mean public disclosure.
I think they mean infinite um infinite money with no oversight
is what they mean, right? They pretty explicitly mean
in my opinion. care like is there unless the money is like drugged
and you like touch it and you're getting hypnotized like what
what is what are we talking about here? >> No, that's actually
so funny because that was the same thing with PB. So they're
like oh down ballot down ballot they they want to get progressive
candidates and I'm like okay but that wasn't my project. My project
was the canvasing operations for the man the general election
for Trump. So So and by the way Jamal Bowman I think was the
only down ballot thing that PV did and he got his dick kicked
in.
>> okay. Yeah. Like, >> so if we're going to play
this game where you have to see the funding from some of these
smaller creators, then fine. Then all of you should start posting
tax returns. And if people want to normalize that, >> this
is so
brain damaged.
This is not actually a reasonable argument. It's so stupid >> in
this world, man. [__] it. I'm fine with that. We
can normalize the out of it. But whatever definition you're using
for dark money, Taylor Leurren absolutely qualifies. Taking money
from that media, whatever the [__] group, that is
easily dark money under any definition that she would use. So,
if we're going to use the dark the dark money, then everybody
and you can see I haven't gone through all this yet, but like
the Young Turks raised a whole bunch of [__] >> everybody
when everybody's talking about dark money in politics, they're
talking about 501c4s that allow unlimited contributions so long
as they don't like uh what do you call it like coordinate with
campaigns >> money I think the Hill raised a whole bunch
of money from from some external finance Glenn Greenwald raised
like $7 million like all >> dark money is like almost explicitly
and it's what Taylor's talking about the 501c4 things with like
uh super PACs like it's it's this exact thing.
>> All these people have relied on external funding for
all other media media organizations. Not me by the way. But I'm
just saying that like if people are if people want to do this
then fine then let's all post our 1040s. Like let's do it if
that's what you want to do. But don't but but all of what I'm
saying I'm right now I'm playing the game by saying that. Not
playing the game. The reality is Taylor the Rinse doesn't give
a about any of this. They just want to destroy it. That's all
they want to do. >> Well, and that's what I was going to
say is like the the main takeaway that I would want to articulate
is that like I too instinctively
believe that it's not ultimately about disclosure because if
if they disclosed it then they would just move the bar. Exactly.
In my opinion, >> where's getting fun? Where's 1630 getting
fun? Who are these people? Yeah. >> What what it's really
about is it's about creating the narrative.
I don't know why you have to self victimize when I literally
lay out the exact things I want for this to be like totally fine
in my opinion.
Why is the v why is the victimization required?
>> Why why do we have to
are not political campaigns? I know um
neither are super PACs. Um
>> I don't know why they have to self victimize like this.
They're like, "Oh, even if we even if we did exactly what they
said, they want more." No.
I don't I don't know why we have to pretend.
>> I uh maybe you know what there's maybe they're just
talking about Taylor >> and reinforcing
of the uni party that's bought and uh bought and sold.
>> I don't know if I'm saying that properly, but I'm tired.
>> But it's bought and paid for by the donor class who
holds it holds back the interests of the left. Hold backs the
interests of the far left. And so as a result, what they're trying
to do is they're trying to uh demoralize liberals from defending
liberals so they can get a bigger >> capture the party
and coup the party. That's what they want to do. >> I think
so. >> Yeah. 100%. And they're not part of the party. That's
why I don't like the Oh, you use that term crabs in a bucket.
They're not crabs in a bucket. They're evil people invading the
bucket. And it's not a circular firing squad. It's just a firing
squad. Um these are just people who are enemies to the party
and they they want to take over the party. They should go make
their own. Tell them the [__] off. >> Who's
going to fire back? >> We we have to. But this is why I'm
saying and again not to I love him. Okay. Is I don't know but
like for peace or whatever, right? Remember one of the groups
we argued about before was the
>> Those guys are standing huge on Taylor. I'm sorry. >> I
feel like that tell the rent that's a testing point. If you're
a huge Taylor sport on that article, that's great. Go make your
own party. Get the out of Don't pretend you're a [__]
>> By the way, do you know the exact reason that is why
it is, right? It's because enough of Destiny's enemies support
Taylor Ren and are like, "Oh, this is really weird to just lie
about her over this article and enough of the people he likes
support Chorus.
It's just very very easy calculus, right? That's all that's happening."
>> Hold on. So, what's so funny about that though is um
the the Vanguard boys, and I want them to hear this, okay? >> Their
creators I don't know if they have like 100k subs or something,
>> but their big fish for who they are and how recently
they started creating. >> Why does he say Vanguard's not
crystal ball? He would say crystal ball and Kyle, I think. I
think he would say get them all out of here. But it's just like
it's just him. It's just boring. And it's it's in my opinion
why like nobody nobody does take him seriously. They're starting
to realize that he's not somebody you can take seriously as a
political actor in any way, right? Because obviously
I think no matter what you'd have to admit that a lot of people
are lying about Taylor Ruins.